Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hast du dein, hast du deinen Doktortitel noch?
Äh nicht.
Das liegt ja auch im Trend.
Wozu braucht man einen?
Genau Konstanze, wofür brauchst du einen Doktortitel?
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, ähm das ist für die meisten Menschen dann erstmal die Herausforderung, so eine Arbeit zu schreiben, oder? Was ist denn das für eine Eingangsfrage? So hatten wir das überhaupt nicht abgesprochen.
Keine Ahnung. Ich find's auch doof.
Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, die Antriebe von Leuten sind unterschiedlich. Manche haben einfach Lust, also das zu untersuchen,
Oder sich dir irgendwie die Herausforderung zu stellen? Ich weiß nicht.
Andere haben nicht die Lust, sich der Herausforderung zu stellen,
Wollen aber trotzdem den Doktortitel haben? Uh, äh Schabernwitze. Schabbanwitze.
Oh äh Schabernwitze. Sie hat heute Morgen verkündet, sie wird nicht zurücktreten.
Kein Umständen.
Das kann man sich auch gar nicht vorstellen. Als ob der andere das machen würden.
Wir wollen Schamanen zurück.
Wie lange das hält, ne? Schauen wir mal, wie lange das hält.
Ich denke, das kann sich ziemlich lange halten.
Ich glaub da freuen sich auf jeden Fall so einige jetzt für das schöne Thema im Wahlkampf.
Ich möchte, ich ich prangere an, dass das Verlieren von Doktor inzwischen,
seiner Bedeutung verwässert wird, ja? Das das war früher war das was Zeremonielles heute, ist das einfach, heute steht das, gehört das zum Lebenslauf dazu, ja? Das war früher ein großer Initiationsritus, sein Doktortitel zu verlieren.
Früher war, früher war alles besser.
Gehört das zum guten Ton.
Wie auch immer, wir machen hier äh trotzdem weiter, wir kommen alle bei äh Logbuch äh Netzpolitik und ihr werdet schon äh mitbekommen haben, wir haben heute Besuch bekommen und zwar haben wir eingeladen, Konstanze.
hallo Casanzer. Denn wir haben ja letztes Mal schon äh etwas vergeblich versucht ähm,
zu ziehen, was die Internet-Onquete äh äh betrifft,
festgestellt, dass uns so ein bisschen der Einblick fehlt. Du warst ja Teil dieses ganzen, dieser ganzen Operation und äh da haben wir so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass sie vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Einblick hast, die du mit uns teilen möchtest,
Fangen wir denn damit an oder wollen wir äh noch was anderes vorziehen?
Ich glaube, wir müssen noch kurz die die Meldung äh verkünden. Leider haben wir jetzt nicht den Elysee-Palast oder so um äh diesen bahnbrechtigen, das bahnweichende historische Ereignis zusammen mit Erik Schmidt an,
Zu geben, aber ähm ich denke, auch hier aus der Metaebene muss,
historische Ereignis gewürdigt werden, dass Google und Frankreich sich gar nicht.
Also tatsächlich die Schlagzeile.
Das ist unglaublich, oder? Also es ist so ein bisschen.
Historisches Abkommen, Freitagabend Erik Schmidt und.
Äh worin geeinigt haben, also es geht mal wieder hier um sein Lieblingsthema, Leistungsschutzrecht in gewisser Hinsicht, äh was ich allerdings nicht genau weiß, ist, inwiefern entspricht denn dieses äh Leistungsschutzrecht, was da in Frankreich eingeführt wurde oder werden sollte,
Wird ähm den Ideen, die wir jetzt hier schon seit längerem immer wieder hin und her mit.
Nee, also eigentlich geht's ja vor allen Dingen darum, dass Gesetz vermieden wurde. Also, dass dort kein Leistungs.
Damit wir keins brauchen.
Ne? Äh und die haben halt so eine Art Lösung, dass die äh neue, innovative Geschäftsfelder fördern wollen. Das gibt Geld, wenn ich mich richtig richtig erinnere.
Sechzig Millionen Euro.
Nee, ich glaube, sechzig waren's Erste und fünfzig. Sind's jetzt? Oder andersrum? Na gut, äh sechzig Millionen?
Ein Fonds für Innovationsprojekte für das digitale Publizieren. Genau. Wird jetzt erschienen. Und der dafür gibt es kein Leistungsschutzrecht.
Das heißt, sie lassen sich von Google so eine Kulturmaßnahme fördern, die sie sonst nicht selber bezahlen könnten und dafür gibt's dann auch kein Gesetz. Aha.
Also es gab monatelange Verhandlungen über ein Gesetz zum Leistungsschutzrecht. Das wurde jetzt im letzten Moment abgewendet, dadurch, dass Google
einmalig sechzig Millionen Euro in einen Fonds für das digitale Polizien einzahlt und ähm die Verleger und Google
Eine umfassende Zusammenarbeit bei der Online-Werbung.
Das heißt, dass die französischen Verleger die Services von Google über die Werbung betrifft, buchen müssen. Das heißt, Google kriegt auf jeden Fall wieder rein, wahrscheinlich, ein Vielfaches. Also, die haben sich dafür einig, dass sie mit Google Werbung machen,
ist für Google.
Ist unfassbar.
Das Lustige ist, wie Christoph Käse versucht, diesen Fail als Gewinn zu verticken. Also er hat ja nun mehrfach sich geäußert auf Twitter ganz viel, aber auch in seinem Blog.
Christoph Käse beim Springer Verlag, der äh zuständige Lobbyist und äh Hauptakteur hinter diesem ganzen LSR.
Wie er versucht, das hinzudrehen.
Es ist un- und.
Verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, was die sich da alle für einen Schuh anzieht. Ich meine, Huns, also.
Geschichte gewinnt, ne? Es ist ja ein historisches Abkommen. Also man muss sich vorstellen, also es geht genau, die die Online-Werbung läuft jetzt irgendwie exklusiv über Google. Es wurde dann irgendwie der die Vermutung geäußert, dass sie denen vielleicht Sonder kommen.
Konditionen einräumen.
Selbst wenn es vollkommen klar denn das wäre natürlich ein Präzedenzfall gewesen, den man vermeiden wollte.
Aber was war denn der Plan, also sind dieses Gesetz in Frankreich überhaupt schon mal formuliert worden oder war das auch eher nur so eine vage Drohung.
Also ein Entwurf wurde auch mein Französisch ist nicht so toll, aber ich habe versucht, äh das ein bisschen nachzuvollziehen, auch ob die so ähnliche Regelungen wollen. Und bei uns ist ja schon äh schon mehrfache Iteration. Wir haben ja schon einige Sachen wieder aus dem Entwurf gestrichen
ist präzisiert worden. Soweit war definitiv in Frankreich noch nicht.
aber diskutiert haben die auch ziemlich hart, weil kann man auch nachlesen. Aber ich finde, es gibt immer wenig Übersprung. Also die äh das hat mal jemand aus dem Französischen überträgt ins Englisch oder Deutsche. Das ist selten und deshalb gibt's immer finde ich wenig Kommunikation. Ick weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber ich finde das immer ein bisschen schwierig
Männer, okay, der Google sprache Wandel ist besser geworden, aber ich,
Findet ein bisschen schade, weil die ja da eigentlich, also die Debatte auch mal Belgien hätte man ja bisschen paralleler führen können und sich auch ein bisschen kräftemäßig vereinen können,
Aber kann ja noch, kann ja noch werden, also.
Vielleicht überhaupt mal eine europäische Vision äh entwickeln, weil das ganze Thema ja ohnehin.
Manchen Punkten gibt's da durchaus. Also ich finde, in manchen Punkten klappt das, aber in manchen Sachen ist das. Also ich meine, Jeremy macht da tolle Arbeit. Er hat immer wieder auch Teile von der von dem französischen Diskurs ins Englische übertragen, was total wichtig ist, finde ich.
Jeremy Zimmermann von Lackfaderator äh Dunette, genau. Wir haben es hier auf aufgetragen. Äh die Namenserwähnung dann auch.
Akronyme.
Verdeutlichen, genau, weil letztlich soll die Sendung ja hier auch den Zugang zu den Themen fördern. Ähm.
Äh also interessant ist, ich glaube, ist relativ offensichtlich, dass die französische Verlagsbranche da jetzt eine,
Einen besonderen Sieg davon getragen hat. Interessant finde ich also diese.
Auf was das überhaupt für eine.
Erik Schmidt und und äh Franoise stehen Freitagabend vor der Presse und sprechen von einem historischen Abkommen. Ich meine, wenn du ein überleg mal, also wie wie völlig wie völlig bizarr das ist.
Ausgerechnet auch noch in Frankreich, ja, also die auch immer so Kultur, Vogt sind, ja, äh legen sich dann sozusagen ausgerechnet auf Google äh äh fest sozusagen, um ihre tollen Presseerzeugnisse zu vermarkten. Haben die Angst,
nicht mehr der Kunde werden oder was?
Also die sind ja nicht Kulturvob, was die ja sind, äh sie sind vor allen Dingen frankophiel, also sie sind ja auf.
Ja, das, Entschuldigung, ich habe das auch falsch ausgedrückt. Also so äh die Phobie äh erstreckt sich sozusagen der gegen den Angriff von außen. Man kennt,
Jahr, ja, genau, also so dieses äh oh Gott, wir werden vom Englischen äh überrollt und im Radio muss jetzt so und so viel Prozent französische Musik gespielt werden et cetera.
Donateur, statt Computer, nicht wahr? Die haben ja immer noch ihre.
Eine andere Sache, ne? Was auch eher kontraproduktiv ist meiner Meinung nach, ne, weil man sich dann eben äh schlechter äh davon auch abgrenzen kann. Das gibt's ja auch ähnliche Gleichnisse in der Schweiz. Egal, ähm alles sehr unverständlich.
Ist ein anderer Kenntnis auch, dass äh unglaublichen Monopols und der Macht, die Google hat. Also ich meine, es ist ein Staatspräsident, das muss man sich mal überlegen. Äh ich meine, es ist Wording.
Sechzig Millionen, ja ich meine allein allein den Presseevent äh kriegt man mit so einem Betrag ja schon gut abgesetzt, so nach dem Motto, ja, ich komme nicht, wir machen immer eine Verlautbarung mit dem Präsidenten und so.
Man müsste das mal auf die Einnahmen pro Woche runtermappen, ne? Das haut wohl ziemlich hin, oder?
Ja, also völlig, völlig, völlig unklar und im Prinzip äh hat man ja auch so den Eindruck, dass auch die Verleger in Deutschland eigentlich genauso frei drehen und sich am Ende auch irgendwas aufzwingen lassen, was sie eigentlich nie hätten haben wollen.
Hä, ich glaube, die Verleger gibt's nicht mehr. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass es sehr unterschiedliche Haltungen gibt, die sich entwickelt haben. Und das ist natürlich große Verleger und kleinere äh auch ziemlich unterschiedlich sind, als auch die einzelnen Häuser,
unterschiedliche Haltung haben. Also das Kinder verlangen's mehr von der da der Käse immer schwadroniert. Das ist nicht mein Eindruck. Also wenn.
Nicht geschlossen.
Ja, aber auch die Berichterstattung zum Beispiel der Süddeutschen äh und der FAZ oder auch sowas wie die TAZ, die sind sehr unterschiedlich. Hier ist.
Was denkst du denn, worauf's hinausläuft mit dem Leistungsschutzrecht?
Ähm.
Das kann eigentlich nichts werden und wird spätestens vor dem Verfassungsgericht enden, wenn nicht vorher doch irgendjemand zu Sinnen kommt.
Äh die erste Frage ist ja, ob sie äh in dieser Legislatur, was sie ja müssen, um diesen Entwurf durchzukriegen. Ähm.
Ob sie's überhaupt noch schaffen, ja. Mhm.
Zeitlich klappt. Meine, die zweite und dritte Lesung kann er zusammengelegt werden, das ist ja möglich. Eine Mehrheit haben sie auch, gar keine Frage. Ähm es gibt Skeptiker, die gibt's in der FDP und in der CDU,
Ich haltet nicht für unwahrscheinlich die Frage, ob es später in Karlsruhe dann ist für mich äh nicht so wichtig, weil ich glaube, dass man's vorher schaffen musste zu verhindern.
Ja, wir hatten ja in der letzten Woche auch die neue Bundesratsmehrheit, die sich ja sozusagen auch schon vor, äh, Beschlussfassung da noch.
Eher eine Verzögerungs Taktik, aber würde ja schon reichen, weil das ja alles relativ knapp ist. Also ich würde ungern drauf ankommen lassen, ehrlich gesagt. Ähm.
Verhinderbar.
Ja, aber ist nicht so, dass ich das für sehr äh wahrscheinlich heute,
Es ist so, muss man schon so sagen, wenn der Mauer irgendwie außerhalb der Netzblase guckst, ist das Leistungsschutz Recht für Presseverleger wenig Thema
Auch die große Google-Kampagne hat eigentlich nicht dazu geführt, dass du da außerhalb von den Leuten, die sich dafür wirklich interessieren, große Wellen geschlagen hat. Muss ich echt sagen,
ist anders als bei anderen Thema, überhaupt nicht vergleichen irgendwie mit acta oder die Netzsperren.
Nee, es ist ja auch schwer greifbar. Ist ja auch etwas, was jetzt unmittelbar erstmal so den Einzelnen so gar nicht tangiert, ne, sondern halt irgendwie große Firmen äh auf beiden Seiten.
Ich finde ja immer so toll, wenn jetzt die großen Portale der deutschen Verleger, diese riesig, riesengroßen Google Banner haben. Wir wissen, ihr habt in der Brause, wo man einen Werbebanner sieht? Müsst ihr euch mal eben, müsst ihr manchmal eben besorgen, weil die haben.
Ich äh habe so was als Backup, ja.
Auf dem Telefon auch. Also da ist es ja schwieriger diese äh egal. Äh haben die immer die riesen Banner für diese Google-Kampagne auf ihren äh Startseiten. Äh äh Frontseiten, wie heißen die denn? Äh Startseiten, ihr wisst schon.
Genau. Auf der Homepage, genau. Also ich finde es großartig, weil sich google ja damit also kauft sich da ja dann,
den Space und die Berichterstattung selbst ist ja relativ dünn, also relativ wenig.
Interessant finde ich, wie jetzt von den Presseverlegern äh Slash Christoph Käse das gesehen wird, der einerseits sagt,
Ähm dass es irgendwie gut das oder das zeigt, dass äh das Beispiel Frankreich zeigt, dass irgendwie Handlungsbedarf besteht. Gleichzeitig sagt er aber, ähm,
was ich, was ich mehrmals jetzt vielleicht könnt ihr mir helfen, das zu verstehen. Er sagt, der äh das hierzulande geplante Leistungsschutzrecht, sei aber noch besser
Diese französische Lösung und passe eher in die liberale Tradition des Landes,
Deutschland in dem Fall, ja? Also wir wir haben eine liberale Tradition, mit der wir uns jetzt Gesetze auf,
also das verstehe ich nicht.
Das musst du dich aber auch mal in so ein Käse hineinversetzen.
Muss halt ein positives Wort haben, aber wie kann der sich denn äh also wie kann der.
Muss er mal in seiner Denkwelt denken.
Wie weit geht denn die Tradition da zurück in seiner Sichtweise? Weiß ich auch nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht genau. Und äh äh.
Na ja, Leistungsschutzrechte sind alt, richtig alt, natürlich. Hat ja mehrere Dekaden aufm Buckel. Äh Buckel. Ja.
Caden. Ja gut.
Aber quasi sowas wie, also wäre es nicht von meinem Verständnis von liberal,
Liberal leer, wenn jemand sagt, okay, wir wir errichten eine Fonds und dafür äh geben wir euch einen Knebelvertrag. Das ist doch immer noch liberaler als äh wie ein Lobby in euch ein komplettes Gesetz auf den Kopf.
Ja, weil das ist doch nicht, das meint der doch nicht, wenn er dann meint, ist ähm,
sozusagen diese diese liberale denke, dass man die Freiheit hätte quasi zu verhandeln mit auf gesetzliche Grundlage natürlich zwischen den äh Verlegern, was man damit aushandelt, das ist doch was, der meint, der meint doch nicht,
uns ein Gesetz, das ist doch seine Welt.
Ach so, er meint quasi dann, wir haben ein Gesetz und das nehmen wir dann als Basis.
Genau und dann können die endlich alle um Gate, ob das geht's ja.
Nee, danke, nee, super, das ist wichtig, dass sie mir da mal hilfst, also ich äh verstehe das, denn.
Du musst mir den Käse in dir fühlen.
Ja ich muss ein bisschen.
Käse in dir.
Bisschen mehr Käse. Äh es trägt auch nicht den Charakter eines staatlichen Markteingriffs. Nein.
Nein, eben nicht. Guck, wenn die können da total liberal, frei, frei verhandeln.
Ja, ja, ja. Ja, okay, alles klar, nee, das ist wichtig, dass man.
Wobei, du solltest dir vielleicht die Originalquelle ansehen, wenn du versuchst.
Also Käse im Original, ne? Das ist primär Literatur von Käse ist echt.
Das kannst du später, wenn's um deinen Doktortitel geht, kannst du das vor. Ich habe den Käse im Original gelesen. Oh, wirklich.
Denn es lohnt sich tatsächlich, weil äh nicht wegen der Blogeinträge, die sind oft
Oh mein Gott, es war so fazial bei mir, aber der Käse antwortet auf Kommentare und er tut da manchmal in sehr entlarvender Weise. Also der sucht schon den Dialog, äh bizarrerweise, obwohl er echt abkriegt, auch in seinen eigenen Kommentaren. Aber das ist kein,
Also der antwortet darauf und teilweise auch bemüht sich, seine Argumentation zu erklären. So kann man verstehen, wie der take. Das ist ganz interessant. Also wenn ihr mal krank seid und mal die siebzig Kommentare immer so,
ist schon, ist schon praktisch kein Fernseher mehr zu haben, ne? Kann mal wieder Kommentare bei Käse lesen.
Ich habe ja lange Zeit immer nur dieses äh ach das darf ich ja gar nicht sagen.
Also du redest ja von seinem Blog der Presse. Schau da. Schauer, schau da.
Der hat sich ja nach dem Presseschauer Daniel Schulz, äh der.
Auch lesenswert.
Der tatsächlich lesenswert ist, äh hat er sich dann irgendwie offensichtlich irgendwann Presseschau der genannt, als Hommage an einen seiner größten und
qualifiziertesten Kritiker wahrscheinlich. Ähm was aber an den Anbringen, das ist glaube ich richtig, dass er sagt, diese französische Lösung hat den Nachteil, dass sie sich nur auf einen einzigen Aggregator bezieht.
Also er will auch bei uns hier noch äh River und Consorten.
Anderen Aggregatoren, die in gleicher Weise kopieren haben, die Verlage dort nun kein Rechtsmittel in der Hand.
Sie haben sowieso kein Rechtsmittel in der Hand, aber äh genau, es zementiert im Prinzip diese diese Google-Sache. In andere Richtungen würde er natürlich sagen, uns, dass es ihm mit seinem Gesetzesvorschuss in Deutschland nur um
Google geht, aber da muss man auch wieder käsische Dialekte äh.
Will Käse eigentlich keine Kohle von Facebook und Twitter. Irgendwann die ganze Snippets da. Und in den Apps will der eigentlich, da könnte man doch noch voll Geld einnehmen.
Na ja gut, ich meine, wenn das äh Leistungsschutzrecht zum zum Tragen kommt in der aktuellen Form würde, dass ja auch nicht ausgeschlossen.
Also im Prinzip jeder, der jetzt hier irgendwie äh einen Titel zitiert, wäre ja äh äh schon dran. Und das ist ja das Ding, ne? Also.
Also ich meine bei bei Facebook und Twitter hat sich hinterher.
Ja, es geht ja auch schon um den Titel, so und ähm warum ist auch ganz interessant, gestern war ja äh der äh Abend so, wo dann Matthias Schinder von Wiki Media mal auch so ein bisschen die Frage in den Raum gestellt hat, was denn so,
Probleme, die Potenziellen wären in die halt äh Wikipedia hineinlaufen lassen könnte. Äh ich muss sagen, dass das,
noch sehr ein sehr vager Ansatz war äh es wurde da wenig konkret, aber es wurden zumindest ein paar interessante Fragen gestellt, nicht? Also einerseits,
Naja, ich meine, wenn man halt jetzt zum Beispiel einen Artikel mit Titel dann in einer Wikipedia Seite äh zitiert, ja, also geht's da.
Ja, aber der die das Gewerbe ist doch, du musst ja gewerblich handeln, das ist ja eine Voraussetzung in dem Gesetz.
Ja gut, so, dann ist es aber auch so, dass halt wirklich äh Content auch bei Spiegel Online massiv eingebaut wird. Äh
ohne dass er verändert wird, das heißt, der ist ja dann auch, was war nochmal gleich diese schöne Formulierung, wie der Content zu sein hat, äh
Presseverleger, kompatibel, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau, was die Formulierung war, von welcher Art Content hier überhaupt gesprochen wird,
wenn der eben so ohne weiteres eins zu eins übernommen wird, dann handelt es sich ja offensichtlich bei Wikipedia, um genau einen solchen Content, ja.
Naja, ich glaube insgesamt, wenn ich mir in den letzten Entwurf ansehe, zu Wikipedia, diese Seite wichtiger, nämlich, dass sie eigentlich jemand wird, äh der eventuell in die äh in die Rolle eines Verlegers, also definitiv, juristisch
weil er Content, die haben ja nun mal auch News, stellen die auch zusammen oder sie haben zum Beispiel auch vielleicht die exzellenten Artikel, die könnte man ja vielleicht noch dazu nehmen und dann ist das wie eine verlegerische Leistung und sie könnten eigentlich von Spuren was verlangen. Ich glaube, die andere Seite ist uninteressant,
außer Wikipedia wäre gewerblich, was natürlich sein kann juristisch, dass es so definiert ist, keine Ahnung. Also die sind zwar nicht kommerziell im Sinne von ähm
Profite oder so, aber könnte sein, dass sie trotzdem gewerblich in dem juristischen Sinne sind. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Zu welchem Ergebnis kommen denn Matthias?
Das kam zu keinem wirklichen Ergebnis. Das.
Rechts Unsicherheit.
Es war einfach genau äh im Prinzip war es nur ein Dokument, der der allgemeinen Verunsicherung, die halt durch diese äh ganze Maßnahme äh heraufbeschworen wird,
und meine auch Blogs et cetera mit dieser schwammigen Definition. Ja, wann ist man jetzt gewerblich? Habe ich jetzt Google Adsans drauf? Bin ich dann äh gewerblich? Muss ich dann auch einen sechzig Millionen, die mit Google machen? So, ja.
Hey du könntest eine Stiftung für innovative, deutsche Podcast gründen.
Ja, das könnte ich vielleicht tun, genau. Und dann wird abgesahnt. Na ja, also ist es äh alles sehr äh unbefriedigend auf jeden.
Unternehmen also die Verleger müssten, wenn du diese Stiftung gründest für innovative Podcasts, müssen sie alle deine RSS abonnieren und regelmäßig flittern, genau. Bei der wenn man an Frankreich angleichen will.
Mhm, okay. Sollten unsere Marktdominante Macht äh hier vielleicht mal umsetzen.
Pass auf, dass du da nicht zu groß wirst, sonst musst du sechzig Millionen an die Franzosen zahlen.
Man könnte diese ein bisschen weniger wert. Tim hat übrigens ein Flattershot an, nur so für die unterbewusste Erinnerung.
Meine, wenn die, wenn die deutsche Verlagslandschaft anfängt, unsere Titel abzuschreiben, dann ist ja sowieso verloren. Nicht wahr?
So, haben wir noch was nachzutragen hier zu dem Thema. Ich glaube, äh das haben wir jetzt ganz gut äh eingeengt, oder? Soweit sich das überhaupt einengen lässt.
Ja, kommen wir mal zum zum Kernthema.
Die Enquete, wie lange ist das jetzt her, Konstanze?
Wie lange ist das jetzt her, Konstanze? Na, und waren über zwei Jahre.
Zwei Jahre, ja, wir spulen mal äh zurück. Äh der Aufstand war groß, denn so Solar, alle waren auf einmal unglaublich netzbewegt und man musste jetzt auch netzpolitische Sprecher haben und so weiter in der Politik. Ähm.
Die gibt's schon ein bisschen länger als dann so Solar, aber genau.
Sie mal ernst nehmen oder es durfte auch mal die Kamera eingeschaltet werden, wenn sie was sagen, wie auch immer.
Hörte auf sie.
Und irgendwann äh war es dann auch irgendwie notwendig äh zu sagen, wir tun was. So und äh nicht wahr, wenn man nicht mehr weiter weiß, dann gründet man einen Arbeitskreis und dann wurde äh diese schöne Enquete in ähm
ins Leben gerufen, die Bestandteil wie üblich, aus dem äh gängigen Proports,
wie er sich aus der Bundestagswahl ergeben hat, plus einer Reihe von Sachverständiger, die oder wie heißt das, Spezialexperten? Nein, Sachverständiger,
Spezialexperten, die halt aus ähm ja aus netzaffinen Regionen heraus im Wesentlichen äh ähm bezogen wurden, du schüttelst mit dem Kopf, nein.
Nicht alle, also wir könnten ja nachher mal betrachten, wer da eigentlich saß.
Ja genau, wer vielleicht nochmal ganz interessant zu sehen. Auf jeden Fall, du warst da auch ein äh Teil äh davon,
Ähm wenn ich das richtig sehe, wurden ja die Sachverständigen auch dann von diesen Fraktionen oder von den sich innerhalb dieser Enquete bildenden äh Fraktionen ähm einzeln berufen. Das heißt,
Wurde dann sozusagen von einer Partei angesprochen, ob man denn nicht da hineingehen wollen würde. Bei dir waren's, glaube ich, die Linken.
Alle damals? Ja. Wer also die CSU von sehr vielen Seiten angesprochen worden und es gab zuvor Gespräche mit äh Ausnahme einer Partei mit allen.
Ja, welche das wohl ist.
Also wie kann's sagen, bei FDP?
Die FDP wollte euch nicht.
Nee, wir nicht.
Ach so, aber die CDU hat sich auch gemeldet.
Vor Gesprächen, sogenannte Kamingespräch. Es waren aber relativ viele Leute. Ich würde sagen, zwanzig oder fünfundzwanzig. Also haben sie Parlamentarier und potentielle Sachverständige vorher zusammengeholt und das war so ein bisschen.
Auch naheliegend, dass ich da meine CCC zuwenden, ne.
Ja, war nicht, glaube ich, ja.
Hat's glaube ich keinen überrascht.
Wie kommt es denn jetzt aber, dass ihr eine, dass du sagst, dass eine Ausfall getroffen? Ich hab letzte Woche ja noch hier betont, die Sachverständigen waren ob ihres Sachverstandes dort und äh der theoretisch,
als Sachverständige keine Form von Fraktionsbindung. Also kannst ja eigentlich da reingehen auf wessen Ticket auch immer du möchtest.
Ja, äh aber das spielt natürlich dann letztlich eine Rolle in diesem Spiel im Bundestag.
wusste ich am Anfang auch nicht, wer dich benannt hat. Das war überhaupt keine Frage, als wir, das haben wir auch gemeinschaftlich, ich bin da auch nicht immer alleine hingegangen. Manchmal schon, wenn sich das so ergeben hat, aber ähm,
es war vorher keine Frage zu welcher Fraktion man hört, sondern wir haben andere Überlegungen gehabt, so dass wir uns überlegt haben, mit wem wollen wir denn da überhaupt zusammenarbeiten? Also von wem wollen wir uns berufen lassen? Es waren wirklich andere Fragen, sowas wie,
Äh wenn ihr uns auf ihn beeinflussen und vorschreiben, wollen die eigentlich mit uns kooperieren? Können wir vielleicht äh rückwärts auch Einfluss nehmen, auf deren Politik, etwa in unsere Überlegungen? Wir hatten ja noch keine Ahnung, wie das Spiel aussehen würde im Bundestag,
wir haben da echt auf der Sachebene entschieden, die haben uns dabei Inhalte behalten, unterhalten in Vorgesprächen. Und dann wurde ziemlich schnell klar, dass dass wir mit der Linken machen wollen, weil wir die kannten wir gar nicht, ich hätte zu den vier Abgeordneten, da gibt's ja immer noch die Stellvertreter immer,
zwei Linke drin und die Stellvertreter überhaupt keinen Kontakt. Die kennt auch die Mitarbeiter nicht, die ja den die ja in Wirklichkeit auch viel der Arbeit machen,
war dann, ja, war so die Idee, nach den Gesprächen, okay, was hat uns eigentlich gefallen an den Gesprächen? Was ist für uns akzeptabel, was nicht? Und dann haben wir die gewählt.
Was haben wir euch denn andere Parteien in Aussicht gestellt, dass ihr sagtet, okay, also ich denke mal, der das das Entscheidende wird doch für euch oder für dich gewesen sein, die äh maximale Unabhängigkeit.
So, das wird das einzige gewesen sein, was dich interessiert.
Nee, nee, da war noch mehr. Wir wollten auch ein bisschen rückkoppeln. Also wir wollten auch, dass die netzpolitischen Sprecher und die, äh die sich wirklich auch äh für Technik, Vernetzung, für Technologiepolitik interessieren, auch mit uns zusammenarbeiten. Also im Sinne von Austausch,
So, das war uns schon wichtig
also dass man auch so ein bisschen merkt, ey, die haben Lust auf äh Dialog und ja und auch nicht so ein bisschen, nicht so viel Schaufensterpolitik. Das waren so unsere Überlegungen. Ich will nicht sagen, dass die Gespräche mit den Grünen oder oder oder der SPD oder der CDU vollkommen interessant waren
aber letztlich auch so von der Kultur,
Vielleicht auch, weil wir die nicht kannten. Also ich kannte sowohl Petra Sitte überhaupt nicht. Ich habe vorher, glaube ich, noch nie gesehen gehabt oder so.
Also, dass die beiden äh von den Linken, genau, die der vertreten war.
Wir hatten noch mehr wegen der Stellvertreter, aber die waren auch die, die Hauptarbeit gemacht haben. Ähm,
Jo, war eigentlich sehr schnell klar. Also im Prinzip, als wir raus kamen, wieder aus dem Bundestag, nach dem Gespräch mit dem Linken war die letzte, das letzte Gespräch war von allen, haben wir dann gesagt, okay, das sind jetzt die Linken. Obwohl ich natürlich Vorbehalte hatte, war's ja klar.
Ist eine Partei, ja.
Natürlich, das sind alle Parteien, aber habe auch schon vorbereitet, speziell gegen die Linke,
Also ich meine, ich wohne in einem Stadtviertel in Berlin, wird nach der Wende irgendwie noch zu neunzig Prozent SED gewählt hat, was dann PDS hieß. Also ich habe da auch ideologische Vorbereitungen gehabt,
Aber ich habe dann irgendwann auch gelernt, dass die Wände jetzt über zwanzig Jahre her ist und dass natürlich gibt's noch eine altschneidige Fraktion, mit der möchte ich eigentlich nichts zu tun haben, hatte ich aber auch nicht.
Ja, also da gehören die auf jeden Fall nicht dazu, ne.
Die auf keinen Fall.
Wie haben sich denn dann.
Man muss die auch mal kennenlernen. Ich kann, konnte ja nicht wissen, mit wem ich mich da eigentlich äh einlasse. Und das das hätte ich bei den Grünen, glaube ich, besser gewusst, weil ich einfach äh konnte die von Nutz schon schon öfter getroffen habe und auch äh Tabea Rüssner und die Opposition schon besser
und auch bei den Sozen hätte ick denke ich mehr mehr einschätzen können.
Du kannst ja nochmal kurz aufzählen, also du warst dann offiziell halt für die linke Sachverständige zusammen mit Annette äh Mühlberg, die, glaube ich, bei Verdi äh aktiv ist. Bei den Grünen waren's dann äh Max Beckdal, Jeanette Hofmann,
äh wo haben wir sie jetzt wirklich alle nochmal aufzählen ähm genau.
Wäre nicht uninteressant. Wir sollten dir aber auch charakterisieren, genau.
Du charakterisierst jetzt.
Hofmann ist ja auch schon lange ein bekannter Name, die.
Die hat sich vor allen Dingen mit Internet Governance befasst. Er war ja auch Vertreterin und jetzt arbeitet sie an diesem Google Institut äh weil in der in der Nähe der Universität angesiedelt ist. Da ist sie einer der vier Direktorinnen.
Hat zu dem Zeitpunkt der Enquete-Berufung, glaube ich, aber da gab's dieses Institut.
Nee, das fängt gerade erst an. Ich glaube, es war so zwei, drei Monate, nachdem sich die Enquete konstituiert hatte, äh dass sie den Job angenommen hat,
irgendwie so. Also es war kurz darauf, sie hatte als wir anfing, kam sie immer noch aus London, da hatte sie ja gearbeitet eine Zeit lang. Sie hat so ein bisschen gependelt zwischen Deutschland und äh und England, glaube ich. Und jetzt.
Also auf jeden Fall auch eine Person, die nachweislich viel Erfahrung hat äh mit diesen ganzen Fragen
Muss man, glaube ich, jetzt hier nicht so viel zu zu sagen, Netzpolitik äh Ork und natürlich auch einer, der äh sichtbarsten Sprecher in der ganzen netzpolitischen Diskussion in Deutschland. Dann hatten wir für die SPD,
Alvar Freude auch relativ bekannter Name, hat man auch schon mal hier zu Gast.
Zensur vermutlich zu netzschweren?
Wir hatten ihn einfach mal grob.
War auf dem vorletzten Kongress war das ein Gespräch, was wir geführt haben.
Also er ist
klassischer Aktivist, würde ich sagen. Er hat ein bisschen andere Themen, vielleicht als Zerschnitt, also da ja diese netzsperren Diskussion hat er ja lange dominiert, er hat den Ackerzens so gegründet
Gerade wegen so einer Haltung zu Vorratszeitensprechung. Aber ich denke, er hat zumindest,
Also auch technisch eine Menge beizutragen. Erzählen tut man ihm in vielen Dingen da nichts vom Pferd.
Er ist mir.
Er hat ja auch eine lange lange äh Vergangenheit, was das betrifft, gerade eben diesen Netzsperren auch schon damals mit seinen mit seinen äh.
Assoziationspflaster.
Genau, also er hat da ja sozusagen auch schon so auf künstlerischer Ebene einiges äh gemacht vielleicht. Für mich die Gelegenheit, auch mal auf CRE neunundzwanzig äh hinzuweisen.
Oh.
Mit ihm über seine ganze äh Vergangenheit et cetera ähm hingewiesen habe. Damals ging's halt konkret ums Telemediengesetz, aber die Themen an sich, die wir da angesprochen haben, gelten irgendwie auch noch heute.
Mach doch mal einen Link zu dem äh neunundzwanzig, der so lange.
Das ist schon wirklich ziemlich alt. Mai zweitausendsechs, aber das ja, ist alles noch irgendwie aktuell. So, dann haben wir hier noch Lothar Schröder.
Der ist eigentlich ein Gewerkschafter und äh ist bei Telekom Lothar Schröder ist eigentlich sehr ja auch Verdi, genau,
Äh sehr bekannt, denn er war einer der Opfer des Telekom-Skandals, einer der abgeschnorchelten. Hat auch äh sich da sehr lange mit auseinandergesetzt. Äh aus meiner Sicht ist es auch ein Aktivist, zwar nicht in unserem klassischen Sinne, aber,
auch in vielen Sachen aus meiner Sicht sehr kompetent, auch Arbeitsrecht natürlich und Datenschutzüberwachung,
kompetenter Mann, der auch äh so ein bisschen mediativer Art hat und manchmal die Gemüter, wenn sie denn da hochkochten, auch beruhigen konnte.
Oha, das ist ja auch eine Qualität, ne. Dann haben wir hier noch ein äh Professor Doktor Wolfgang Schulz.
Dass der Leiter äh des Hans-Predo-Instituts für die machen so Medienforschung vor allen Dingen in Hamburg.
Mhm. Sehr etabliertes Institut, muss man dazu sagen, ne? Also, predo ist äh ein bekannter Name, ne.
Nicht so viele, die mit diesem Profil in die Deutschland, ja,
Also sicherlich äh grade in dem Bereich Medienpolitik ähm aber generell glaube ich auch diese Medienkompetenzthema. Da ist er ziemlich fit. Hat sich auch sehr eingebracht.
Und äh Cornelia Tausch.
Ist eine Lobbyistin für den VCPV, der Horrorzentrale Bundesverband, die äh,
Ja, setzt sich vor allen Dingen für Verbraucherschutz, Recht und Datenschutzrecht ein, ist auch sehr kompetent. Ähm natürlich ist es teilweise auch zum Vorwurf gemacht worden, dass sie eine bezahlte Lobbyistin ist. Aber aus meiner Sicht ähm,
sind die Verbraucherzentralen Lobbyisten anders zu sehen als die klassischen Wirtschaftslobbyisten. Auch selbst mal gesagt, weil ich natürlich in der Enquete auch öfter mal über die Lobbyisten äh Hatern habe,
Also,
Ich finde aber, dass eine Vertreterin der Verbraucher anders zu sehen ist, als klassische Wirtschaftslobbyisten. Wie kann man jetzt so und so sehen? Das ist meine Meinung. Ich denke, sie vertritt äh berechtigte Interessen, auch wenn man natürlich manchmal
Die Verbraucherzentralen auch kritisch sehen können, aber das kann man ja für alle.
Ja, der CCC ist ja auch im Lobbyistenverzeichnis eingetragen, also von daher.
Ich würde den Begriff ohnehin nicht ablehnen, aber so wie ist das eben für mich nicht obby ist.
So, dann.
Heißt das.
Was? Ach so, äh.
Haben wir doch vor einigen Folgen gelernt von ähm von Kirsten Fiedler.
So eine Art Neusprech für.
Also der Lobbyist für für Bürgerrechte und das Gute heißt nicht Lobbyist, weil Lobbyist die negative Kontation hat und aus diesem Grunde heißt der Manager.
Ich möchte mich jetzt hiermit nicht umbenennen. Ich sehe auch.
Du willst richtige Lobbyist, Lobbyistin sein?
Ist doch, man kann es doch auch äh Politikberaterin nennen, wenn man so will, ja. Wobei Beraterin geht ja auch überhaupt nicht, wa? Man sollte dann so, ist ja auch voll äh.
Ist auch sehr negativ behaftet, ja.
Äh ach ja.
Regierungslager für die FDP, Sachverständige waren ein Hubertus Gersdorf.
Für die hat viel uns geklaut, ja können wir nachher nochmal drauf kommen, also.
Hat der euch Lebenszeit gekauft?
Äh gab zu Anfang der Enquete. Mein Witz, da hatte er sich, äh hatte er zu Protokoll geben lassen, dass man doch hier nicht äh für die,
basteln sollte, zu sagen äh und seine Lebenszeit klauen sollte durch zu lange drehen und es dann in der Folge doch sehr häufig,
selber sehr lange ausschweifender Reden da bekannt geworden. So gab's dann mal diese Lebenszeit klauen Witze.
Philipp Bastard, es sei denn, ich, ja, okay.
Also äh vom vom von seiner Attitude Atitüde sehr profesoral und und juristisch eben.
Ja, was qualifiziert ihn jetzt eigentlich so als Internet? Äh.
Der hat sich so mit Medien hat recht schon befestigt. Der ist zuvor nicht als Experte aufgefallen. Denke auch nicht, dass er technisch äh immer auf der Höhe war, muss man aber auch nicht sein. So in der verschiedenen Sichten in die Enquete eingehen,
war ja keine Technik äh Runde, sondern sollte er möglichst von vielen Seiten,
betrachtet werden. Gab da schon einen gewissen Überhang an Juristen? Das lag aber mehr an den Abgeordneten. Da sind ja auch viele Juristen dabei.
hat mich auch oft gestört, dass man die, dass man immer entlang der Gesetze argumentiert hat,
Ist aber häufig so. Also ich bin ja dauernd von Juristen umzingelt.
Hast du den Eindruck, dass Juristen ähm eher entlang der Gesetze als entlang des Sinns der Gesetze argumentieren?
Nee, das würde ich so pauschal nicht über alle Juristen sagen wollen, aber ich habe natürlich bei bestimmte Art des analytischen Denkens haben, die kommt sicherlich von ihrem Studium her. Das ist oft sehr schematisch und durchprüfend so. Man nimmt sich die Aspekte her und,
so. Klar, verstehe ich auch so, sind ja sozusagen die Prüfungsleistungen da aufgebaut, in gewisser Weise,
aber hm mir ist das oft nicht holistisch genug und ich kann auch nicht leiden, also ich mag nicht, wenn gibt ein Teil von Juristen, die so die Technik wegdrücken, sich die gern so hindefinieren,
und dann ja.
Finde das immer ganz interessant, so dass äh Wechselspiel,
die Logik und die Analyse Art der Juristen versus die Logik und die Analyse Art der der Techniker ja, im Prinzip haben ja beide so einen Hang äh dazu und sind dann auch teilweise eigentlich auch sehr vergleichbar, ja?
Ja, an manchen Punkten kommt man gut zusammen, das stimmt. Ja. Also ich will, ich will auch gar nicht so pauschalierend über Juristen reden, weil ich wirklich sehr, sehr unterschiedliche kenne.
also da will ich gar nicht so, aber natürlich äh ich sage mal so, Professoren, die an der an der Universität lernen, haben natürlich auch einen gewissen in der Regel so einen gewissen Stil entwickelt, einfach weil sie Vorlesungen halten nach einer bestimmten Art.
So dann gehen wir noch mal hier durch, dass wenn ich zu viel Zeit mit der Sachverständigenliste äh verlieren, aber ich finde es trotzdem mal ganz wertvoll, mal so ein bisschen zu.
Die richtige.
Wer denn da eigentlich so dabei war. Äh Doktor Wolf Osthaus.
Ja? Der ist bei Eins und Eins.
Genau United Internet äh AG, also.
Wie du ihn bezeichnen würdest?
DE, GMX. Ich kenne ihn nicht, von daher habe ich jetzt.
Ich meine Lobbyist oder nicht?
Na ja, zumindest würde ich sagen, hat ja eine mehr Business ähm orientierte Sicht der Dinge vermutlich, oder?
Das ist wohl wahr, ja. Also, ja. Er ist ein netter Mensch so und auch kompetent, aber.
Auch sagen wir mal kein kein Fehler, ja. Ich meine, wenn man sich über Internet und digitale Gesellschaft äh unterhält, gehört ja sicherlich auch dieser Blickwinkel in irgendeiner Form dazu.
Weil du glaubst, dass die Parlamentarier nicht zu Genüge einbringen oder wie?
Lasse ich jetzt mal äh offen so, ja, aber ich denke, dass das hier auch Teil der Überlegungen war, zumindest was die FDP betrifft, wenn nämlich überrascht, dass jetzt nicht, dass ausgerechnet die FDP äh auch in diesem Bereich ähm,
nach potenziellen Teilnehmern Ausschau äh gehalten hat.
Natürlich. Also äh in manchen Dingen ähm,
Grad soweit Breitband äh Infrastrukturen und so betrifft, war natürlich auf der Höhe, hat aber auch teilweise also äh der neigt halt auch, wie wie viele denn zu einer gewissen Realitätsverweigerung,
Immer so bei LTE-Netze und so geredet haben, merkst du natürlich schon, ähm dass sie bestimmte Dinge einfach auch nicht nicht zugeben wollen, die offensichtlich sind, ja. Also was zum Beispiel gerade bei LTE-Netzen, das ist halt grade jetzt ganz wichtig Marketing-mäßig. Das hat mich dann teilweise schon geärgert,
Aber andererseits ähm gab's schlimmere.
Okay.
LTE-Netze, die Mobilfunknetze der vierten Generation.
So nennen willst.
Wahrscheinlich noch nicht die, mit der wir wirklich glücklich werden. Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich noch auf die fünfte warten, aber immerhin schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne. Aber wir lassen uns nicht über Technik reden, lass uns über die Sachverständigen reden. Der dritte und letzte von der FDP, benannte Sachverständige, ist Paddelun.
auch äh in unserem Umfeld kein Unbekannter,
durch seine Arbeit für den Fürbot, die sich jetzt irgendwie umbenannt haben. Ich weiß aber nicht mehr genau wie.
Digitalcourage.
Ach ja. Der war auch dabei.
Für die FDP. Damit haben wir dann die Liste der Sachverständigen abgeschlossen.
Nee, nee, da fehlt noch diese Unionsfraktion.
Dann gibt's ja noch die, die dürften auch ganz viele Sachverständige äh äh reinschicken, weil die sind ja wichtig. Und,
tja, wenig überraschend, da ich als Erster wurde hier,
also als erster in der Wikipedia gelistet, das äh ist natürlich hier keine Rangordnung. Dieter Gorni äh benannt, sicherlich eine der streitbarsten äh Personen, was diese ganze Urheberrechts und äh Kriminalisierungs äh Debatte et cetera betrifft seit
vielen, vielen, vielen Jahren hatte ich das überrascht, dass der berufen wurde.
Ja, war auch so toll, als er einmal, als er leider einmal nicht so richtig aufgepasst hat, wo er seine Hand heben muss, äh die, die, die Union hat er immer am Block gestimmt. Dann hat er mal für Creative Comments gestoppt, war ganz großartig. Wurde aber natürlich wiederholt.
leider ein Irrtum. Ja, der vollsten war ja natürlich auch ein CDU da und.
Vielleicht lädt er sich ja zu Hause heimlich auch Musik aus dem Internet.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Weiß das schon, was der Gornie so macht, wenn er alleine ist.
Die Frage war halt ähm also warum man auch, warum man A überhaupt äh so einen hauptberuflichen Lobbyisten sich einlädt, aber die andere Frage ist natürlich auch, inwieweit man das Profil der Sachverständigen, wenn man die jetzt alle mal sieht anguckt,
Ich denke zu vielen Themen, die dort besprochen worden sind in den vielen Projektgruppen, hatte natürlich die Diagone nicht zu sagen. Der ist ein Spezialist sozusagen für die ganzen Urheberrechte und Medienfragen und hat da auch eine sehr,
klare, ja, klare Sicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob es klug ist, sich in Sachverständigen zu holen, der eben für eine Sache,
Wobei das man das, glaube ich, über viele ja mehrere Sachverständige sagen könnte. Aber mir fehlt nur so auf, also weiter im Sachverständigen tralala.
Kann man sagen, dass Dieter Gorni der ähm ein oder einer der einflussreichsten oder der sichtbarste oder ja der Lobbyist für,
Urheberrecht in Audiobereich ist.
Ja, komm, man kann schon sagen, dass er sie sichtbar ist und sehr aktiv.
Ist halt der, der auf jeden Fall die Kapazität hat, da äh überall mitzumisch.
Hat auch die Verbände hinter und deren zu sagen Potenz.
Nur zur Einordnung.
Ja, dann äh Harald Lemke wurde noch von der CDU benannt.
Mhm. Da das jemand, der sich seit vielen Jahren mit Verwaltungs-IT befasst, äh hatte äh in verschiedenen Ländern. Ich habe die Länder aber nicht im Kopf äh da bereits gearbeitet, strammer CDU.
Hessisches Innenministerium, sehe ich hier.
Genau. Keine weiteren Fragen?
Ja, Inpol, aha.
Beim BKA. Ja. Mhm. Hessische Polizisten.
Okay. Also man sieht schon so seine Hobbys. Ähm Wolfditer Ring.
Ja, das, der ist ja eigentlich vor allen Dingen bekannt für die ganze Debatte, um den Jugendschutz, in der es äh.
Der bayerischen Landeszentrale für neue Medien.
Genau. Ich denke, das ist äh äh mit Abstand der der Älteste natürlich unter den Sachverständigen. Das ist, glaube ich, der Grund ist eher noch dazu suchen, dass die Netzsperrendiskussion so äh nah dran war. An an der Einsetzung der Enquete und,
dass er damals diese Kommission, die sich mit Jugendschutz in Ländern, Land und Bund und so befassen, noch eine relativ große Rolle gespielt haben.
ich weiß nicht, ob er zu irgendwie anderen Themen da auch eine Meinung hat, aber er hat immer die Hand an der richtigen Stelle ausnahmslos gehoben,
Man muss sich schon klar machen, dass also da dieser Verständigen der Union niemals auch nur abgewichen haben, war immer ein Block.
Immer.
Also mit Ausnahme von.
Ja Bernhard Roleder.
Ist der Hauptgeschäftsführer der Bitcom. Äh also.
Bundesverbandes für Informationswirtschaft, Telekommunikation und neue Medien? Ja.
Der Club der einzige Sachverständige, der auch mal Vertreter schicken konnte, wenn er nicht da war.
Weil er sich's leisten konnte.
Äh also hauptberuflicher Wirtschaftslobby ist. Aber also durchaus will die Kompetenz zumindest in so so diese Breitbandzugang Netzding. Das kann man wohl nicht bestreiten.
Ja, dann haben wir noch äh Christoph Weinhardt. Professor am Karlsruher Institut für Technologie.
Mhm. Das hat, ja, akademiker, so ist,
Na ja, das lag ein bisschen daran, dass wir überhaupt nur in einer äh Gruppe mit ihm mal zu tun hatte. Kann nicht mal sehr viel sagen über über ihn, weil man natürlich nicht an allen Projektgruppen teilnehmen konnte. Und so hat's bei uns sich sehr gematcht, aber er hat halt immer,
auch richtig abgestimmt.
Und auch richtig abgestimmt hat dann wahrscheinlich auch noch die letzte äh im Bunde hier Nicole äh Simon, die glaube ich die einzige Podcasterin ist, die eine Enquete war, wenn man dich mal rausnimmt.
Hat ein Buch geschrieben übers Internet.
Buch hat sie geschrieben.
Ich hatte hatte sie bereits kennenlernt in den Vorgesprächen, ähm die dir gab mit der CDU.
Twitter. Twitter mit hundertvierzig Zeichen zum VIP zwei null meinte das Buch.
Ja. Ja.
Das ist ja interessanter Titel.
Okay. Ja. Das ist halt so als Social Media Beraterin äh unterwegs.
Wusste wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Social Media Berater dahin. Und die CDU hätte ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen albern ausversehen, wenn ausschließlich Männer waren ja nur ausschließlich Männer, auch die Abgeordneten. Ähm das hätte wohl ein bisschen komisch ausgesehen.
Äh richtig, stimmt, ach so ja, bei den Menden, stimmt's? Ja, ja.
Die Männer waren auch äh alle Männer bei der FDP.
Verstehe. Nicht nur bei der ja genau, bei der FDP.
War immer lustig, also bei der die also man sitzt ja auch sozusagen nach man sitzt, fand ich am Anfang sehr merkwürdig bei den Fraktionen, was ich nicht für selbstverständlich erachte.
Ja. Habe ich auch.
Dann hat man äh immer so den bunten, lustigen Block, also mit Frauen und bunt gekleideten Menschen auf der einen Seite, auf der anderen Seite hat man die ganzen Männer und Nicole Simon,
die Männer alle am Anzug fand ich immer lustiges Bild, also das war auch irgendwie passend von der Optik. Wir mussten uns ja durchsetzen.
Naja, du hättest ja die zweite Frau da sein können, ne? Würdest ja offensichtlich auf.
Ihr musstet euch als als Frauen durchsetzen.
Nee, als Sachverständiger, ich,
Anfang der ersten Woche immer darauf bestanden, dass wir nicht als Fraktion betitelt werden wollen, aber gegen zum Beispiel so die Frage, wo man sitzt, das war überhaupt nichts zu machen, weil wie selbstverständlich, dass du man zu den Fraktionen gesessen hat. Ich habe mich da auch immer bis zum Ende hin auch immer gewehrt, ja.
vereisamt zu werden.
Also die Sachverständigen, um das jetzt nochmal zusammenzufassen, haben wir im Prinzip so eine Verdopplung dann dargestellt, weil man eben genauso viele Sachverständige dazugeholt hat, wie ähm.
Wollen wir die jetzt auch noch alle durch.
Genau. Wobei es jetzt noch ein äh achtzehnten äh Sachverständigen auch noch äh gab und das war sozusagen das das Internet.
Nö, die Öffentlichkeit.
Öffentlichkeit, genau.
Nicht nur das Internet.
Wurde ja äh da da mussten wir leider jetzt zu unserer Schande äh letztes Mal äh feststellen, dass wir da nie so wirklich reingeschaut haben. Ich weiß nicht, wie
die Beteiligung letztlich tatsächlich war. Wie ist denn dieses Experiment gelaufen?
Also eingesetzt wurde eine sogenannte online Beteiligungsplattform, die heißt Adhocracy,
auch so ein bisschen in mehreren Stufen, also das heißt, die äh Entwickler haben auch ganz konkret mit äh der Bundestagsverwaltung zusammengearbeitet so, gab's da noch ein paar Treffen ganz am Anfang. Es war ein bisschen Streit,
wie man diese Onlinebeteiligung durchführt und was für Tools man anwendet. Letztlich hätte die Enquete dann diese ähm einen Block.
Feedback war glaube ich auch im Gespräch, wurde dann aber so wegen Piratennähe irgendwie nicht so toll gefunden oder was.
War schon eher nee, ich glaube nicht, dass das mit Piratennähe war. Nee, ich glaube, das Team war einfach sehr entgegenkommend,
und die Funktionalität war okay, wartet, was der Bundestag gerne wollte, sozusagen. Dann gab es den Twitter-Kanal und äh anfangs ist auch so ein Forum,
Na ja, das Interesse war auch am Anfang, muss ich sagen, ziemlich groß, das heißt, es gab sehr schnell über tausend Accounts, das hat wenige Wochen gedauert, also sich Leute einen Account gekriegt haben und mitgemacht haben
Aber es kam natürlich auch sehr schnell raus, dass das eigentlich ähm
die normale Arbeit in den Projektgruppen nur schwer einzubinden war und das auch nicht alle Abgeordneten daran oder Sachverständigen irgendwie Interesse hatten. Also man muss sich auch praktisch einbringen, ja? Man hat irgendwie Themen an der Projektgruppe, muss man kann man sich ja mal überlegen,
Und dann,
Noch viel mehr Vorschläge von dieser Onlinebeteiligungsplattform. Wie baut man die ein in den Arbeitsfluss? War ja ein fettes Programm. Wir wussten ja schon am Anfang, von dem Einsetzungsbeschluss, dass wir quasi äh irgendwie so.
Wie wie von mehreren leerstehenden Uni-Programmen abzuarbeiten hatten, etwa er unglaublich breit. Ähm und am Anfang kam auch richtig Vorschläge so,
mitdiskutieren, die haben unsere, die Papiere, die wir in den Arbeitsgruppen dann da reingestellt haben,
diskutiert, aber es hat nicht wirklich dazu geführt, dass es ähm,
Wo ich einen Arbeitsmodus gab. Es gibt eine Ausnahme in der Projektgruppe, hat's ein bisschen anders gemacht, nämlich genau Demokratie und Staat, die haben's ein bisschen anders probiert, aber in den meisten Projekten konnte man noch irgendwann als Außenstehender nicht ordentlich mitarbeiten, denn,
die Mehrheit und die Mehrheit ist ja immer die die zu sagen Regierungsmehrheit hat beschlossen, dass die Projektgruppensitzung nicht öffentlich sind,
Damit war natürlich total schwierig, sich an den Diskussionen überhaupt zu beteiligen, wenn man dann denn nur noch in Textwüste mit Verzögerung auf diese Plattform äh hochgeladen bekommen hat,
Und dann haben sich auch keine Community bildet. Also.
Das heißt, du meinst daran hat's im Wesentlichen gekrankt.
Mehrere Gründe, das ein Grund, auf jeden Fall, die die Nichtöffentlichkeit der Projektgruppen. Wie willst du denn mitdiskutieren, wenn.
Nee, ist vollkommen nachvollziehbar.
Und dann diese Themen der Community Building im Sinne von, das sich das irgendwie parallel abgebildet hat zu den Projektgruppen,
Am Anfang wartet noch ganz okay, da erarbeitet wirklich eine Gruppe von Leuten, die sich etwa bei den ersten Gruppen wie Netzzentralität oder Datenschutzer so eingebracht hat oder Urheberrecht, auch weil die besonders umstritten waren,
aber es gab so nicht diese Pendant zu denen und Kette, Projektgruppen, also auch regelmäßig, werde die auch inhaltlich hätte vor sich her treiben können.
Das heißt, du sagst nicht, dass das nicht hätte funktionieren können, aber es könnte unter diesen Bedingungen nicht klappen. Hm.
Aber ich sehe auch äh ein bisschen so Legitimations,
Fragen, die sich mir stellen, die hätte ich vorher nicht. Ich habe auch, glaube ich, anders vorher auf den Liquid und diese
äh zur Entwicklung geguckt, diese Onlinebeteiligung. Ähm jetzt stellen sie sich mir natürlich andere Fragen, nachdem ich äh ist ja auch einen gewissen Einblick, den ich gewonnen habe in dieser ganzen parlamentarische Arbeit. War mir viel war mir vorher so nicht klar,
Also wie arbeiten die eigentlich diese Abgeordneten und wie ist so der Modus? Und welche Rolle spielt die Bundestagsverwaltung? Und welche Rolle spielen die Mitarbeiter und so? Das wusste ich ja vorher nicht.
bin jetzt skeptischer als früher, nicht nur, weil nicht gut funktioniert hat oder nur in ganz kleinen Teilbereichen überhaupt funktioniert hat, sondern auch mal der legitimatorische Gründe sehe.
Kannst du das ein bisschen ausführen? Also Legitimität, für was.
Ich bin eher so ein bisschen angeödet gewesen von diesem ganzen Ding. Mir war das fremd.
aber es hat natürlich seine Ursachen, diese Provozen, also dass sie immer alle auch den Vorsitz der Gruppen, ja, wer wie in den Projektgruppen und in der gesamten Enquete abstimmen kann, wer eine Runde irgendwas sagen kann, dazu kann ich vielleicht nachher nochmal sagen, ist ja egal.
Jedenfalls äh diese Proports ist ja aber eigentlich tatsächlich irgendwie so eine Verlängerung des Wählerwillens. Äh es gibt da Mehrheit in diesem Bundestag, die finde ich nicht gut
aber mit denen muss ich leben. Und äh so eine Beteiligungsplattform kann natürlich diesen äh diese Regeln, die sich,
Aus den Wahlen ja jetzt nicht ergeben irgendwie torpedieren.
Beziehungsweise folgt denen erstmal gar nicht.
Nö, im Gegenteil ist ja so ja sehr gut untersucht, dass die Online,
Aktivisten, eine vollkommen andere Wahlstruktur haben. Das ist ja bereits untersucht. Ich glaube auch, äh Linus, du hast es mal von Netzpolitik geblockt, ne? Das war nämlich äh ganz deutlich verschoben gegenüber den Wahlergebnissen und sehr deutlich attraktiv links.
Das wundert glaube ich kein.
Nee, wundert keinen. Na ja, äh da stellt sich natürlich für jeden, der da gewählt ist,
im Bundestag gewählt zu werden, schon nicht so einfach. Stellt sich natürlich die diese Legitimationsfrau, warum soll ich mich von irgendjemand, der sich einen Account klickt,
da Vorschläge machen lassen so. Und vor allen Dingen dann kommt die Frage auf, wenn es irgendwie zwingend wird. Man könnte sich ja zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass das ein,
Nummer nicht, dass du diesen Vorschlag so konkret gibt, die besten drei Vorschläge, die war ja auch ein Voting dabei, wie man wollte, müssen behandelt werden, könnte man ja sagen,
in Ausschüssen. Ja, wir haben hier diese Beteiligungsplattform und die besten drei, die nach oben gewollt werden, müsst ihr besprechen,
Nicht, dass man die annehmen muss. Ja, nicht mal, dass die umgesetzt werden müssen, aber die müsst ihr zum Thema machen. Da stellt sich sofort die Frage, warum.
Meine, das ist ja ein generelles Problem solcher Beteiligungsplattformen, ne, was ist so die Grundgesamtheit und woraus setzt sich das zusammen und wer darf damit spielen? Deswegen hätte ich das ja persönlich,
sehr viel interessanter gefunden. Ich weiß, dass es genauso wenig durchsetzbar gewesen wäre, aber interessanter gefunden hätte ich's auf jeden Fall. Wenn zum Beispiel die gesamte Enquete sich eine äh eine solche Plattform,
Ich kenne jetzt nur Liquid Feedback äh äh besser, es adroggressiv funktioniert, glaube ich, hat im Wesentlichen dieselben Ziele, funktioniert im Detail, etwas äh anders, da muss ich wohl nochmal ein zu machen. Das auch verstehe. Ähm
So, dass man dann sozusagen innerhalb der Enquete mit diesem gesetzten Proports, der ja da ist, sozusagen über die Themen,
diskutiert. Das wäre ja ganz äh spannend gewesen.
Da reden wir doch mal über diesen Proports. Die Enquete unterscheidet sich ja gerade von den anderen Ausschüssen, die ja auch alle nach Proports äh besetzt sind, nämlich die gesetzgebenden Ausschüsse, so die im,
Die Entwürfe der Gesetze beraten,
Ich glaube, Gesetzgebende Ausschüsse sind hier richtig Wort, aber ist egal. Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Der Unterausschuss neue Medien, der Innenausschuss, der Rechtsausschuss, lalala, Landwirtschaftsausschuss. Unterscheidet sich ja gerade darin,
das eigentlich der Proports hier ausgehebelt werden soll, denn es ist ja eine Untersuchungskommission. Du hast keine unmittelbare Wirkung auf den Gesetzgeber, du hast den zukünftigen Gesetzgeber beraten. Aber
Durch die Tatsache, dass sie die Sachverständigen in den Fraktionen einfach zugeschlagen haben, äh war von Anfang an ab der ersten Sitzung klar, die haben irgendwie eine Stimme Mehrheit,
ich habe das erste Jahr nicht verstanden am Anfang, dass die diese Bundestagsdenker übernehmen wollen,
ich war Anfang war auch total krass, war natürlich die zum Beispiel eine Medienliste machen für die Sachverständigen,
aber sehr schnell sehr schnell. Ich war nach der ersten Sitzung klar ist, äh dass die von der Union alle mit der Union stimmen. Das war mir am Anfang überhaupt nicht klar. Und ich find's auch nach wie vor keine Selbstverständlichkeit. Offenbar fandet alle anderen vollkommen normal,
Also normalerweise wird's ja genau diesen eigentlich aushebeln, indem du die Hälfte genau die Hälfte zahlenmäßig mit den achtzehnten Sachverständigen sogar ein Mehr aus diesem Protzigen rausreißt,
nur, dass die Sachverständigen der Union, äh, na ja, die.
Schon äh auf Linie gebracht wurden, bevor sie berufen wurden. Ja.
Heit mit der Sitzordnung an, muss ich schon sagen. Also man hat da nicht die Abgeordneten, die man ersetzt und auf die anderen Seite eben die Sachverständigen, man hat die zugeordnet. Und da habe ich dagegen habe ich mich natürlich auch gewehrt.
Also diese diese Proportsache ist ja insgesamt oder überhaupt diese ganze Fraktionssache ist ja schon eigentlich ein riesen,
Riesenthemenfeld, ne? Ähm man man stellt sich natürlich die Frage, warum soll da überhaupt irgendwas stattfinden, wenn wenn dieser Proports dann noch ähm,
reproduziert wird, ja? Ähm das war ja auch eine eine Frage, die sich dann durchaus von einigen der Sachverständigen an einigen, an mehreren Stellen öfter mal gestellt wurde.
Ja. Habe ich mich ja dann auch gefragt, klar.
Wie wie war denn jetzt mal so, wenn wir jetzt mal so schauen, ähm ich glaube, dass die formale Gegebenheit haben wir jetzt, glaube ich, ganz.
Vollkommen frei formal. Du kannst so abstimmen, was du willst. Du hast auch Rechte als Sachverständiger.
Genau, trotzdem passiert das nicht. Der ist ja eigentlich
man nennt das, glaube ich, irgendwie so so Habitus, ne, dass einfach dass die Leute, die sind halt einfach daran gewöhnt, ja, die sind daran gewöhnt, das wird hier alles äh ne, wir halten alle zusammen, wenn wir das nicht machen, dann äh
sind wir wieder in Weimar und dann kommt Hitler oder oder irgendwie so 'ne Vorstellung scheint da irgendwie so.
Die Sachverständigen sind keine gewährten Abgeordneten.
Genau, trotzdem haben das, weiß ich nicht, wie wie viele Sachverständige haben das, na sagen wir mal so, wie oft ist es denn passiert, wenn du jetzt sagst, äh die Sachverständigen als Unabhängige, wie oft ist es denn passiert, dass du dich von deinen.
Dauernd. Also ich habe also natürlich wusste ich, wie ich wusste nur, äh,
Wie die Linksfraktion stimmen wird, weil die sich natürlich vorher abstimmen. Sie sagen, also das lehnen wir ab, das finden wir guter, wenn wir uns wohl eher enthalten. Ich keiner Weise hat mich konnte mit denen stimmen oder auch nicht.
Was hast du an den Gesprächen teilgenommen?
Nedet nicht, also es gab manchmal so Treffen, aber in der Regel bist du in diese Tagesgeschäfte im Bundestag, da du ja nicht da bist vor Ort, du kriegst oft nur die Ergebnisse, es kommt noch dazu. Es gibt nur Obleute runter in dein,
die Abwörterrunde. Er dient wohl in allen Ausschüssen gibt, ist eine Fünf-Mann-Runde. Alle Parteien sind da keine einziger Sachverständiger,
selbstverständlich. An der Opt-Leuter-Runde wurde sehr viel abgesprochen. Und du kriegst dann als Sachverständiger sozusagen über die Fraktion das Ergebnis der Rune, weil übrigens nicht immer gleich war. Weil das ist ja ein bisschen wie wie Buschwung, ne,
kriegst halt sozusagen von deinem Vertreter, der bei mir zur Linksfraktion gehörte, das Ergebnis der Runde. Die anderen Sachverständigen haben teilweise andere Ergebnisse bekommen. Das ist ja dann so eine Frage,
der rauskommt. Aber vor allen Dingen, wenn niemand von den Sachverständigen dort vertreten und das fanden die alle normal.
Mhm. Obwohl es ja eigentlich so in der Definition äh eine Enquete heißt, dass es überfraktionell ist.
Nee, natürlich. Ich habe, ich sehe mich nach wie vor so. Natürlich habe ich mehr. Ach, warum auch?
Ja, das heißt, du hast auch nicht immer mit den Linken gestimmt? Ja, wissen wir nicht. Vielleicht haben die so gute Ansichten.
Wir haben oft dann zusammengestimmt, wenn wir zum Beispiel zusammen gearbeitet haben, also wenn,
nicht in allen Projektgruppen so aktiv und dann hätte war ja auch noch äh zu sagen für andere Projektgruppen zuständig, wenn wir was zusammen erarbeitet haben, wenn das wirklich ein gemeinsamer Text war, das finde ich ja völlig stimmt,
aber das war nicht immer ein gemeinsamer Text. Äh klar. Warum auch?
belastet eigentlich heute noch relativ äh erstaunt zurück. Äh äh wie schnell man in diese Sitten und Gebräuche da reinkommt.
Schleifen sie schnell ein, oder? Wenn, wenn alle.
Wenig, die hinterfragt werden.
Du wirst auch, du wirst wahrscheinlich auch müde, dass jedes Mal zu hinterfragen, ne? Also wenn du weil das wahrscheinlich sich in jeder, in jeder einzelnen, jeder einzelnen Amtshandlung da äh widerspiegelt.
Ja, nee, ich hatte das aber auch jedes Mal angemerkt. Also, ihr kennt immer so ein Beispielzeug. Ich hatte ja, ich habe ja ein paar Beispiele mitgebracht. Also, war ganz viel.
Also du als Revolutionärin bist natürlich nicht müde geworden, das anzuprangern, aber der Rest war da wahrscheinlich dann irgendwann auch.
Wie jedes Mal. Nee, manche haben wenige haben das gemacht. Wenn du so einen so einen anderen hast, ich habe jetzt mal eben mitgebracht, dann hast du die Fraktion SPD, Linke Bündnis neunzig grün, das kommt mal vor, das wird sozusagen die Oppositionsfraktion sich zusammentun und dann sind die Namen.
Also wir wir haben vor uns wir haben jetzt vor uns liegen ein äh Enquete-Kommission digitale Gesellschaft, Projekt, Gruppe Netzneutralität,
Antrag der Sachverständigen, Alvado Constanze kurz, Markus Beckedal und der Fraktion der SPD, Linke und Bündnis neunzig die Grünen.
Das heißt, wir haben darauf bestanden, dass wir nicht zu den Fraktionen gezählt werden, sondern natürlich, für uns selbst. Arbeit hat sich von Anfang an nicht etabliert, dass die Sachverständige eine eigene Runde bilden oder so. Es gab am Anfang so ein Treffen,
man sich mal kennenlernt und so, aber es war total klar, dass man den zu den Fraktionen gehört. Es gab da nur so eine mini Runde.
Wobei man kannte sich ja jetzt auch schon, also ich meine, wir waren ja nicht alle, aber einige schon.
Freunde schon.
So, auch Paddelun, weil sozusagen ja nicht unbekannt äh.
Ja auch da die die Rolle habe ich nie wirklich verstanden. Er hat ja viel Kritik dafür bekommen, dass er gegen seine,
Prinzipien, die er ja seit vielen Jahren äußert, gestimmt hat, ans faktisch dagegen oder sich enthalten hat. Ähm und er hat jetzt im Nachhinein viel damit argumentiert, dass er,
äh zu sagen, ja in den internen Verhandlungen so viel erreicht hätte. Ich habe da kein Verständnis für, habe ich ihm natürlich auch oft selbst gesagt. Warum, warum, nur weil mich die FDP benennt? Warum sollte ich gegen meine eigenen Überzeugungen stimmen?
die er ja auch seit vielen Jahren äußert.
Welche Überzeugung meinst du da jetzt?
Alles Mögliche, Datenschutz, war Datenschutz, das war eine Zentralität, war Urheberrecht. Er hat sich halt vor allen Dingen häufig enthalten,
wenn er nicht derselben Meinung wie die Fraktion war, aber ich sehe halt diesen diesen ganzen Zwangsweg überhaupt.
Ja
Also das, da kannst du dich natürlich irgendwie, dem kannst du nachgeben, aber warum eigentlich?
Wie? Inwiefern hattest du den Eindruck, dass vielleicht von Seiten der Fraktionen ähm der,
eigentliche Motivation zu sein schien sich mit der jeweiligen Person zu schmücken,
Also ich meine, äh als als SPD zu sagen, wir haben denen einfach Freude da, wir als als Grüne zu sagen, wir haben den Markus Becker da, als Linke zu sagen, wir haben die Konstanze kurz da, so was so wie unsere Frau äh oder unsere Jungs in der Enquete. Ähm,
hattest du den Eindruck, dass das,
vielleicht so die instrumentelle Ansicht, die instrumentelle Meinungen oder das Instrument Verhältnis war, dass sie zu euch hatten.
Jetzt haben wir uns natürlich schon gefragt, bevor wir überhaupt äh äh.
Überhaupt da rein.
Ersten Jahr überhaupt die Gespräche geführt haben, ob das was für eine Art von Vereinnahmung das ist. Da habe ich och halt schon lange mit mir gehadert,
mich auch mit anderen natürlich beraten, ne. Ich bin ja auch nicht neu gefragt worden, also noch andere Personen gefragt worden. Äh eine Zeit lang sah so aus, als wenn zwei vom TCC, in der in der Kommission für verschiedene Fraktionen sitzen würden. Das kam dann aber anders, egal. Ähm,
ich denke mal, für mich war es, glaube ich, ein bisschen Glück, denn die Linke ist natürlich im Bundestag immer so eine Art Underdog. Die kommt sehr oft in die Rolle, dass wenn die Linke vorschlägt, schwimmen sowieso alle dagegen. Das ist nun mal auch so ein gewisser Habitus, der sich,
bettet hatte. Na ja, das ist, nee, das ist schon anders bei anderen.
Total übel, oder? Also das ist auch wirklich übel, wenn du wenn.
Find's furchtbar ideologisch. Ähm war mir vorher auch nicht so klar. Habe ich erst gelernt im Bundestag, dass die also so ein bisschen so die Schmuddelkinder sind. Hm na gut,
Ist jetzt nicht so überraschend, ja, aber ähm ist eben so.
Insofern also ich habe das immer als so ziemlich kollegiale Sache empfunden, die gerade die Mitarbeiter, mit denen man ja auch viel arbeitet von den verschiedenen Abgeordneten, die sind halt einfach,
Fitte Leute, die auch Bock auf Diskussionen haben, auch Austausch von denen man was lernen kann, aber die auch gerne von einem selbst lernen. So, die waren echt viel sachlich.
toll. Habe ich nicht gedacht. Also äh so ist es aber auch oft mit den Mitarbeitern jetzt,
bei den Sozen oder bei den Grünen, da gab's ja auch oft Zusammenarbeit, dass man sagt, okay, also können wir vielleicht zusammen eine Position finden. Zusammen heißt, können die Parteien sich einigen und welche von den Sachverständigen würden sich anschließen?
Das spielt eine Rolle. Das Denken kommt man auch relativ schnell rin. Aber,
Ick habe das eigentlich als so ziemliche Arbeitsatmosphäre empfunden und nie mich nie so als oh, die halten mich jetzt da als ihr Schild vor. Ich glaube, es hätte mich auch stört, wenn ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt so,
Finden würde ich habe natürlich im Nachhinein betrachtet mehr Kontakte heute zu den Linken,
und ich glaube auch, dass gewissen Einfluss gab auf ähm die Netzpolitik der der Linken.
Wir sind da jetzt mal auch mal so konkret deine Rolle. Ich meine, du bist ja im Prinzip,
nicht, also offiziell bist du ja als Person da äh hin äh
bestellt worden, aber es ist ja auch offensichtlich, dass du quasi auch äh ob deiner Sprechertätigkeit des CCC an der Stelle auch äh gefragt warst.
Würde ich schon meinen.
Und damit äh stellt sich natürlich sozusagen auch eben für den Club,
die Frage, ja, ich meine, ist ja auch, sagen wir mal, in der allgemeinen Diskussion sicherlich nichts Neues, dass im Club schon mittlerweile so eine gewisse staatstragende äh äh Rolle äh unterstellt wird, wie ist denn da diese Debatte
geführt worden. Also was waren denn so die Überlegungen, äh die zu einem ja oder nein?
Ja Elli will natürlich mehrschichtig. Ja, es war mehr als eine Ebene von Diskussionen. Das Erste war, geht mal überhaupt zu so einem Vorgespräch und macht,
sich da reinzusetzen,
Klima war ja damals auch sehr aufgeheizt. Der Zugangserschwerungsgesetz, das war ja richtig Streit so. Hm, der zweite war,
gucken, hören wir uns mal an, wer geht denn da hin?
andere Personen angefragt wurden, das war ja so ein bisschen Kinderzimmerdiplomatie. Habt ihr überhaupt Interesse? Würdet ihr vielleicht kommen zu so einem Gesprächen? So,
Ick besteht da eine Chance oder redet ihr gar nicht mit uns oder auch so ein bisschen bei den Abgeordneten, die man ja nicht kennt, ob man sich abkann, ja?
irgendwie gibt es da eine gewisse Sympathie und eine Grundlage für Zusammenarbeit, so so ein bisschen Hintergrund, Diplomatie. Na ja,
Und äh für mich selber jetzt als Person äh waren mehrere Sachen ausschlaggebend zum einen.
Habe das sicherlich auch als eine Ehre empfunden. Also der Bundestag sitzt noch Enquete-Kommission ein äh und sie fragen mich, ob ich,
Mit meiner Expertise mitwirken will, war für mich schon Überlegung, ähnlich wie, weiß ich nicht, wenn,
Gericht Umstellung gebeten hat. Also der Faktor spielt schon eine Rolle. Und kann man sich aber sagen, na ja, vielleicht ist es sowieso, also das ist ja so ein bisschen mit Fefe jetzt,
viel geschrieben hat. Also ein blödes Feigenblatt, damit stellt man Aktivisten ruhig, beschäftigt sie, macht ihnen ganz viel Arbeit. Diesen Aspekt habe ich damals nicht so gesehen, weil mir auch nicht klar war, wie viel arbeitet wird.
Ja genau, kommen wir doch mal dazu. Also das.
Keine Ahnung, also.
Die These lässt sich ja auf jeden Fall mal ergründen, so ähm ihr habt auf jeden Fall viel Arbeit gehabt. Ich sehe jetzt hier ähm
mich würde jetzt also im Prinzip zwei zwei Aspekte der Frage. Erstens, wie viel Arbeit war's? Und zweitens, äh wann ist da am Ende bei rausgekommen? Ja, also wie es aussieht, wir haben noch gar nicht so darüber gesprochen, was ist das Delivery Bo?
Enquete-Kommission. Zwölf Berichte zu bestimmten Themen.
Ja, ähm die Berichte.
Welche zu lesen, dann optional ist für jeden, der sich interessiert.
Es wird sozusagen noch eine Generaldebatte geben zum Ende, also wenn der Endbericht wir haben ja die letzte Sitzung schon hinter uns, der Entebericht kommt. Ähm der Enquete-Bericht und äh der Bundestag wird
debattieren, das heißt die Fraktionen werden sich dazu nochmal äußern, das wird wahrscheinlich auch eine richtige Debatte und nicht zu Protokoll,
das ist wohl üblich, wenn man die Umkehr beendet. Werdet Ergebnisse im Wesentlichen ein sehr großer Bericht,
Also viele hundert Seiten. Der zum einen eine Bestandsaufnahme ist über die verschiedenen Themenbereiche, also weil das der Ist-Zustand und dann Handlungsempfehlungen enthält.
Wer hat den äh Wert das geschrieben?
Wir alle zusammen,
Und da natürlich in äh recht vielen Punkten Distanz waren und alle die Möglichkeit, jede Mitglied der Möglichkeit Sondervoten abzugeben. Gibt halt auch immer,
Möglichkeit, diese Sonderwurden als Altertiefmeinung oder einer Tiefhandlungsempfehlungen reinzuschreiben,
Man kann die auch Minderheiten voten, denn ich würde sie nicht so sinn, ähm weil ich mich da nicht als Minderheit ziehe, weil man dann wieder dieses Profortsdenken kommt.
Markus hatte den Begriff, glaube ich, öfter verwendet. Also es.
Fakt, stimmt das schon echt, man hat sich oft zusammengetan. Ja. Also, mehrere Leute haben dann zum, zum, also sich hingesetzt und Texte geschrieben.
Schnappen wir uns doch mal diese Schöne, du hattest da ein ein Blatt.
Äh
Das ist also sehr schön, das möchte ich mal beschreiben. Also ich habe das hier gerade äh in der Hand. Das ist ein, der Bericht zur Bürgerbeteiligung der Projektgruppe Urheberrecht.
Also schon ein bisschen älter.
Eine Seite, ja? Eine Seite da rosten wir zweitausendelf, vierzehn Uhr, wir haben die Seite hundertacht von hundertachtzehn, äh wir haben da Zeilennummerierungen dran und dann,
Ist das so eine Art einen Moment?
Mhm.
So eine Art Diff auf Papier, ne, da ist dann eingefügt ähm die Fraktion, Bündnis neunzig, ist das ein öffentliches Dokument, ja ne,
Die Fraktion Bündnis neunzig Die Grünen beantragt die Zahlen, viertausendeinhundertzweiundneunzig bis viertausendeinhundertfünfundneunzig durch folgende Formulierung zu ersetzen, das dann so,
Ein Satz. Des Weiteren beantragt die Fraktion Bündnis neunzig die Grünen folgende Einführung in Zeile viertausendeinhundertsiebenundneunzig,
Zeile viertausendzweihunderteinundzwanzig sowie Zeile viertausendzweihundertdreiundvierzig.
Es reicht Linus.
Ja, da geht's dann um den äh viel mehr entsteht der neue Typ, das Prosumenten und dann schlägt die Fraktion die Linke vor den Satz äh dieser Zeile durch folgende Formulierung zu ersetzen und weiterhin das Wort
ProSoment gegen das Wort Produser auszutauschen.
Ja, also es ist nicht mehr der der Konsument und Prosument, Prosument, sondern jetzt der,
Producer und sein Wort, das kannte ich gar nicht, finde ich super geil.
Zeigen soll, ist ja letztlich, wie wie kleinteilig die Arbeit war.
Genau und das alles jetzt auf Papier, ne, also das ist ja total ähm total unfreundlich für jeden. Also da sitzt ja total pasunfreundlich.
Du hattest das auch immer digital, alles gab's auch digital, außer die Tischvorlagen. Äh denn manchmal.
Habe ich ja digital auch nichts von, wenn ich dann nochmal auf die Zeilen springen muss? Oder gibt's denn.
Du kannst Begriffe suchen und teilen und so.
Ja, aber gibt's äh okay, alles klar.
Und du siehst also, du hast zwischendurch auch die Dogs zum Beispiel bekommen, wo du siehst, wer was geändert hat. Die Verwaltung, die Fraktion und so weiter. Also die technisch,
wartet schon leichter, den digital zu durchsuchen, aber das Problem war, dass manchmal eben diese Tischvorlagen dazukamen. Da hat jemand morgens nochmal drucken lassen. Das hast du dann nicht digital. Oh.
Gleich so ein Dokumentenscanner noch äh mitnehmen sollen. Die gibt's auch in portabel.
Also es war wirklich.
Gerade in Dokumentenscanner kaufen.
Naja, also da fällt mir doch gleich was ein.
Was mich jetzt hier interessiert ist, es gibt beantragt, dass es jetzt grau hinterlegt. Heißt das, das wird jetzt, darüber wird jetzt abgestimmt. So und dann steht da noch, die Fraktion die Linke schlägt vor. Dass zwei unterschiedlich.
Genau, dazu ist halt also so Arbeitsmodus. Du siehst, dass sie sich wirklich Absatz für Absatz damit auseinandersetzen und das ist natürlich für diese ganzen Projektgruppen und die vielen Themen in den Projektgruppen einfach unglaublich viel,
wir waren halt teilweise auch also ich meine wir haben halt auch Teil der Texte geschrieben, das war mir vorher nicht klar.
Ja, wer soll denn sonst schreiben?
Naja, mir war nicht äh zu naja, als ich die Enquete einsetzte, habe ich eher so gedacht an diese typischen Anhörungen, die ich ja im Bundestag schon kannte, als Sachverständige. Mir war halt nicht klar, dass da viele hundert Seitenberichte raus äh kommt. Und und dass man,
man schreibt jetzt zu sagen Text nicht wie ich ihn wegen meiner,
als als Wissenschaftlerin, schreibe, schreibe sie ihn, sondern du er wird auseinandergenommen. Weißt du, schreibst viele Versionen, ne,
Also oh, das war mir halt vorher so nicht klar. Ich habe auch meine Arbeitsweise geändert in der in den in den sozusagen Jahren dann. Du lernst ja daraus.
Ja, also da was jetzt also passiert ist, dann wurde in der Projektgruppensitzung, wurde dann darüber abgestimmt über den Antrag, das war dann, was in die Antrag fünfhundert des Tages, Zeile so und so in Zellen so und zu ändern, wer ist dafür, wer ist da.
Ziel war halt am Anfang schon viel Konsens. Man wollte einen gemeinsamen Bericht. Man wollte sich viel einigen. Man hat also immer wieder die Punkte letztlich identifiziert, die Dissens sind. Äh und die,
Ich denke, so ähnlich wird es ähm,
Äh wenn du einen Entwurf hast für Gesetze auch laufen. Kann mir das schon gut vorstellen. Ich meine, da sind ja dann keine Sachverständige nebenbei, sondern nur noch Abgeordnete. Ich vermute, dass es so ähnlich läuft. Viele davon wurde schon in der Obleuterunde. Vorab sozusagen.
Ah, dann haben die schon so ein bisschen.
Da wo so richtig äh Knackpunkt war, das hat uns natürlich gestört, weil die Sachverständigen dann nicht vertreten waren.
Wie war denn aber jetzt, also wie stelle ich mir jetzt das Projektgruppentreffen vor? Wurde dann wirklich einfach das Dokument lag auf dem Tisch und die äh wie, was war jetzt so zum Beispiel die Anzeige? Also ich meine, wenn hier jemand vorschichtet, ein Wort zu ändern,
dann kann ich mir ungefähr vorstellen und das ist auf Seite hundertacht, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, wie die hundertsieben Seiten davor aussehen.
Genau, also tatsächlich, ich habe nahezu themenweise abgearbeitet. Man hat,
zehn, zwölf Mal sich in Projektgruppen getroffen, die sind dann immer so, dass man dann vielleicht so sieben, acht Sachverständige, natürlich auch die Mitarbeiter dabei, muss man schon mal sagen, die auf,
viele Arbeit gemacht haben äh und dann fängt man an, die äh man fängt an, eine Struktur zu entwerfen und dann die Themen durchzusprechen und dann hat man so von Sitzung zu Sitzung äh,
Teams oder Einzelleute, die bestimmte Sachen vorbereiten. Also jemand legt einen Text vor und der wird dann debattiert. Es regnet sehr kleinteilig. Mhm. Ähm,
Die wichtigere Arbeit aus meiner Sicht ist natürlich zu identifizieren. Was wollen wir hier besprechen? Worüber wollen wir uns hier streiten? Und wo sind unser hingehen? Leider war es in fast allen Projektgruppen so, dass die Bestandsaufnahme, also was ist eigentlich der Ist-Zustand?
meist mehr Zeit hatte als die Handlungsempfehlung. Also so ein bisschen weg
vor dem Streit, weil wenn man sich den Enkelbericht wirklich durchlest, sieht man sehr wohl richtige strukturelle Unterschiede in der Technologie, Netz und Medienpolitik zwischen den Parteien. Die kommen da sehr klar raus.
aber vor diesem klaren.
Auch denkpolitischen Schiss mal, was sich da zeigt, wieder zurückgeschreckt. Das so klar zu sagen. Da war viel White Washing. Grade so zwischen den,
im nicht öffentlichen Bereich, in den Projektgruppen gesagten Sachen und dann in der Enquete-Kommission selbst, die ja auch gestreamt wurde,
Wenn man das aber liest, das Dokument, das Ganze und ich meine, ich kenne das halt ziemlich gut. Ey, du verbringst halt viel, viel Zeit mit lesen auch, unglaublich, also so üblicherweise der Sonntag, weil,
Montag war ja, war dann sozusagen Sitzung. Dann sieht man schon sehr deutlich unterschiedlich, richtig unterschiedliche Ansätze, Technologie und Netz und Medienpolitik. Das ist schon deutlich zu sehen. Wirklich auch die,
Würde mal sagen, ideologischen Paradigma im Bezug auf äh liberale Denkweise
Wie siehst du den Menschen als soll da gebildet werden und in die Macht gesetzt werden, selbst seine Sachen zu kontrollieren, das sieht man schon. Also und so, ich finde das Ergebnis gar nicht so schlecht, das ist nur so, dass,
Ich glaube nicht, dass es gut gut verkauft werden kann. Weil einfach dafür ist es so unglaublich viel.
Wie viel, von wie viel Seiten Abschlussbericht reden wir denn jetzt?
Paar hundert.
Mehrere hundert Seiten, also sagen wir mal so fünfzig Seiten pro Projektgruppe oder.
Teilweise mehr, werden Gruppen, die haben auch zweihundert Seiten geschrieben.
Okay, dann dann sind wir in dann sind wir relativ nah oder relativ schnell bei Tausenden.
Dazwischen bricht, hatte fast tausend Seiten. Also klar, äh wir sind ja auch nicht in der Zeit geblieben, das war aber.
Ja ja gut, das war abzusehen.
Einsetzungsbeschlüsse. Sie haben dachte ich, Achtung, meine Güte.
Ja, ja. Also einmal, einmal alles und zwar irgendwie im im Quartal, Ende des.
Natürlich fehlen auch total Sachen, die mir sehr persönlich sehr wichtig gewesen wäre, weil man einfach, wann denn noch? Also wann, dann soll man das nochmal besprechen?
Aber das heißt, alle Streitereien, die dort stattgefunden haben, mit Abstand, mit ähm also mit mit Ausnahme der Adhocy, haben letztendlich sich nur
auf diesen Abschlussbericht von äh letztendlich dann von mir aus äh weit über tausend Seiten. Zu den zwölf großen denke ich korrekt.
aber sehr weit definierten Themen der der Netzpolitik, also da ist glaube ich ständig kaum etwas.
Mehr als Netzpolitik. Ist größer.
Ja, genau, also es ist wirklich gesellschaftspolitisch. Also sehr sehr groß. So und jetzt, jetzt kommt, jetzt kommen diese tausend Seiten. Du hast über zwei Jahre äh deines Lebens jetzt damit verbracht. Ähm.
Ja.
Jetzt jetzt liegen diese tausend Seiten da. Ähm und haben keinerlei ähm keinerlei Verbindlichkeit, oder?
Das ist jetzt quasi zur, das kommt jetzt.
Ist quasi eine Analyse und eine Empfehlung für die zukünftige Sitzgeber, der hat
keiner binde Wirkung in irgendeiner Weise, aber trägt natürlich, zumindest bei manchen Projektgruppen ziemlich dazu bei, dass man den Ist-Zustand für sachlich und dass man sagt, worüber redet man hier eigentlich und war das, was wirklich teilweise auch umstritten, aber in manchen Parkgruppen ist das sehr gut geworden.
So, das heißt, was doch, ähm was man erwarten würde von dem Dokument, ist, dass sich in der Zukunft die Politik,
darauf beruft, ja? Also dass man sagt, äh wie wir im, äh wie sie Enquete-Kommission empfiehlt, beziehungsweise jedes Mal, wenn sich eine
eine oder die Regierung dazu entschließen sollte etwas zu machen was nicht der Handlungsempfehlung entspricht dann kann Jimmy Schulz oder was sich hinstellen und sagen
oder ach so, der ist ja gar nicht. Na gut, der wird ja bald Opposition sein, eventuell noch, wenn die gewählt werden, äh wenn ich.
Und er Abgeordneter ist.
Ja
Ist ein FDP-Abgeordneter, der auch.
FDP-Abgeordneter mit mit entsprechend der der ungewissen Zukunft eines FDP-Abgeordneten. Ähm der,
oder irgendjemand geht jetzt hin und kann dann,
kann er quasi der Bundestagsdebatte sagen, wir haben hier so und so viel Jahre und äh Euros äh auf eine Enquete-Kommission geworfen und ähm ich bitte die die Regierung äh deren,
Ergebnisse zu betrachten oder.
Nee, aber Linus, also so funktioniert auch Politik nicht.
Ne eben, also deswegen frage ich mich, aber es wäre so als Maximum, was ich mir vorstellen könnte, was man mit diesem Bericht noch machen kann.
Also zum zuerst mal, jeder kann sich natürlich auf diese Handlungsempfehlung und aber auch auf die zu sagen, äh Sonderboten, also die Minderheitenmeinungen, ausdrücken, berufen, überhaupt kein Problem,
kannst halt machen. Äh das wird passiert och,
jetzt schon. Ähm zum anderen kannst du natürlich als derjenigen, der diese Abgeordneten im Bund, Bundestag wählt, du kannst sehen, vertreten die und was werden die in Zukunft vertreten? Letztlich bleibt aber der Nutzwert ähm,
eher ein akademischer,
eben nicht wie in anderen Ausschüssen irgendwie in in konkrete Gesetze mündet, aber hatte aus meiner Sicht natürlich ähm den Streit um die um die Technik, Digitalpolitik, Netzpolitik, Medienpolitik, Urheberrechtspolitik äh äh verändert.
Das ist für mich sehr deutlich, denn.
Akademischer Einflüsse auf jeden Fall. Also.
Nee, das hat sie auch auch politisch verändert, denn,
auf diesem geballten Raum und für diese Fülle waren natürlich die gesamten an der Netzpolitik beteiligten Politiker noch nie zusammen. Ja, ich hatte eingangs gedacht, die Piraten würden eine Rolle spielen,
den achtzehnten Sachverständigen mehr greifen können. Und also die saßen auch am Anfang wirklich mit am Tisch so virtuell. Das spielte aber dann gar keine Rolle mehr,
die auch inhaltlich dann also die haben sehr, sie konnten ja nicht so zu dieser Rolle ein,
Wäre eigentlich sehr schön gewesen, wenn man niemand gehabt hätte, von außerhalb äh der, die vor sich her treibt. Äh aber.
Die Öffentlichkeit war dazu aber nicht in der Lage.
Nee, wat sehr schade ist, denn.
Was natürlich auch schwierig ist, wenn so viele Sitzungen dann nicht öffentlich sind, ne.
Und das war auch am Anfang dann so am Anfang mal so Ritual, jedes Mal hat ein Sachverständiger beantragt, dass die Sitzung öffentlich ist und jedes Mal hat die Mehrheit dagegen gestimmt,
Die Rituale haben wir später gelassen, weil der sinnlos war. Und auch nur die Atmosphäre, dann vergiftet. Es gab teilweise sehr vergiftete Atmosphäre. Ich habe auch es rettet zwei Momente, wo ich da mein, gerne meine Tasche hin und meinte, muss ich schon sagen. Also die.
Das würde mich ja jetzt mal interessieren.
Und vor allen Dingen, weil die CDU irgendwann, wenn's richtig kritisch wird und,
sie auch in die in die Problematik geraten, dass sie eventuell eine Abstimmung verlieren, weil ja offenbar der Atomschlag ist, ja keine Ahnung.
Das war der, der große, die große Debatte damals mit der Schmierenkomödie äh.
Dann kommen sie halt mit Geo-Tricks. Ich wusste am Anfang gar nicht, was das ist. Geschäftsordnungstricks.
Das war doch eine.
Die haben uns teilweise auch also da einmal eine sehr angespannte Sitzung da haben die uns sitzen lassen da. Die kamen einfach nicht wieder auf zur Pause. Auch der nicht,
Lassen wir da,
Erst haben wir dann mit dem, also die stellvertretenden, das war damals der Dörrmann von der SPD, der war dann später nicht mehr bei, also die teilweise kommen das mal vor, dass Abgeordnete ausscheiden, weil sie andere Aufgaben haben und dann kommt neue,
ähm der ja, wem gesagt, der machen Sie doch weiter. Also das war auch der, was er drei ist und auch äh.
Was hat er denn da für konkrete Bedeutungen? Also Auswirkungen. Wieso?
Kannst dann ja nicht weitermachen. Ne, wenn niemand hat, also es gab eine Pause, der Vorsitzende geht weg, die mussten sich beraten, war sehr aufgeheizt. Man hat sich halt gestritten, das war damals Datenschutz und der Zentralität.
Ja. Und dann?
Äh und dann kam die einfach nicht wieder aus ihren Beratungen.
Vorsitzenden.
Ja, die ganze Seite war dann leer. Und natürlich, also musst du ja auch überlegen, die Sachverständigen.
Bescheid gesagt, dass sie jetzt nicht kommen oder was?
Gab es unterm Tisch Kommunikation und an Meckereien über Twitter und SMS natürlich. Aber das hat ja nichts damit zu tun, dass wir einfach die Sitzung nicht fortsetzt.
verbracht.
War das jetzt dieser Tag als äh,
Die Abstimmung verschoben wurde.
Hm. Später haben sie dann die Abstimmung, genau.
Mhm. Aber es wurde dann schon doch nochmal abgestimmt.
Ja natürlich, als äh da fehlte ihnen ein Sachverständiger. Sie fehlte eine Stimme.
Mhm. Außerdem fehlt dir eine Mehrheit sozusagen. Ah.
Ja, weil es wäre so bizarr. Also da habe ich auch erst wirklich verstanden, wie wie wichtig die ihn äh das Abstimmen da ist und dass wir nie wieder sachlich reden brauchen, höchstens auch in den Projektgruppen,
Habe ich aber gedacht, ich habe am Anfang gelernt, die Projektgruppe Netzentralität, die meine erste war, die ich auch sehr spannend fand inhaltlich, die war auch wirklich,
der Vorsitzende war Peter Tauber von der CDU, äh eigentlich eher ein Kulturpolitiker, aber er hat das sehr gut gemacht, er war sie hatten auch alle Bock auf was zu lernen. Es gab da einen echt guten technischen Austausch. Ist nun mal relativ technisches Thema,
ähm und dann hatten wir da fertig diskutiert. Dann haben aber die Leute von der CDU, also die Abgeordneten nicht so abgestimmt, wie sie das diskutiert haben,
da habe ich dann gelernt, oh.
Schön, schön, dass wir mal drüber gesprochen haben, aber jetzt müssen wir abstimmen und sie wissen ja, dass es eine andere Welt.
Gelernt, dass also die,
also das sind auch die Fraktionsleitung entscheidet die ja so nicht anwesend ist, ne? Enquete, aber natürlich die der wusste eigentlich, okay, das ist hier her äh das hat ja mit Sach,
Arbeit ist natürlich auch ideologisch. Also man sollte das nicht vergessen. Ich habe eine, ich habe eine politische Meinung. Ich habe ein Bild davon in meiner eigenen Welt, was ähm
dem Allgemeinwohlen nutzt, was ich für eine sinnvolle Technologiepolitik halte und die geht nicht zusammen äh mit mit Vorstellung insbesondere von,
Wirtschaftspolitik,
äh in der Enquete Wahrheit auch Wirtschaftspolitik oft Thema. Das ist nicht mein Thema. Mich interessiere mich dafür, wie wir alle vorankommen. Und nicht, wie man die Wirtschaft fördert. Das ist eine Haltung im Leben,
wohingegen natürlich die Wirtschaftsvertreter sehr häufig sagen, dass gute Wirtschaftspolitik äh gute Gesellschaftspolitik ist, wenn man dauernd Arbeitsplätze erschafft und so. Also das war wirklich ein ideologischer Graben.
Ja.
Und den kann man schlecht überwinden. Ähm und ich habe das eher viel neoliberale Gedanken gut erlebt. Das wird er ja auch nicht hinterm Berg gehalten.
Was würdest du denn jetzt sagen, war das jetzt irgendwie so ein dickes Falkenblatt und schön, dass wir mal drüber gesprochen haben oder hat jetzt äh dieser Enquete auch irgendwas erzeugt oder ist die gestiegene Erfahrung nur äh bei den Teilnehmern, dass man sowas jetzt nicht mehr machen.
Naja gut jetzt fragst du mich jetzt als Person oder fragst du mich jetzt zu sagen, wiegt's im Gesamtzusammenhang, sie. Also, weil das sind zwei verschiedene Antworten.
Ja
Also insgesamt wurde ich schon sagen ähm,
Also für die äh für die viele Zeit und die Arbeit ist es glaube ich zu dünn,
Also zu wenig Handlungsempfehlungen, die ich auch äh richtig konfigiert ist, dass du also siehst, äh wo sind die Konfekten und wie kannst du dich entscheiden?
was für eine Netzpolitik willst du eigentlich? Das ist in manchen Teilen so, in manchen ist das nicht richtig gelungen. Die Bestandsaufnahme ist ziemlich gut, würde ich sagen, aber eine Bestandsaufnahme hat politisch keinen großen Mehrwert.
Nicht doll, einfach weil die Bestandsaufnahme natürlich in zwei Jahren obsolet ist, weil sie dann eine andere Bestandsaufnahme notwendig wäre. Äh die Technik entwickelt sich ja dynamisch. Persönlich ist es für mich natürlich äh also mehr als ich dachte, ein großer Gewinn.
Also kenne sehr genau die Positionierung und die Begründung äh aller Parteien dazu,
Kenne die Haltung der des politischen Sprecher oder auch der Fachpolitiker jetzt, die jetzt nicht nur Netzpolitik machen, sondern auch andere Bereiche, die in der Enquete besprochen wurden. Das ist für mich sehr wertvoll zu wissen, auch warum,
Auch wie die langfristig ihre Position sehen. Äh ich weiß, was über die Person, mit wem kannst du reden, wer ist,
verbohrter Vollhorst. Ja, ist wichtig. Du kennst die Mitarbeiter, du weißt, was davon ähm wirkliche Leistungsträger sind, also wer sich auch wirklich auskennt,
Das ist schon, also für mich persönlich hast du äh richtig interessante Einblicke, wie.
Okay, also ich meine, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen, dass das äh.
Mir fiel es nicht klar.
Viel Arbeit und so weiter, aber am Ende äh äh versteht man natürlich das System besser. Ähm für die Öffentlichkeit wär's natürlich jetzt eigentlich viel interessanter gewesen. Man äh könnte sozusagen dasselbe eben auch äh über die Enquete als solche und deren Ergebnisse.
Es gibt eine Sache noch für die Öffentlichkeit. Ich denke schon, dass es eine einsteinde Sache ist, dass der Bundestag erstmalig so ein Onlinetool verwendet hat. Auch gegen teilweise den Widerstand der Bundestagsverwaltung. Die auch mal einen Podcast wert wär,
Ähm denn das ist natürlich, da waren wir weit vorne.
Podcast über die Bundestagsverwaltung gemacht.
Also können wir uns ja mal überlegen, äh welche anderen ähm Parlamente sowas schon haben in Europa, ist echt selten. Und da äh ist schon mal ein Schritt,
auch, dass nicht alles funktioniert hat bei dieser Online äh Beteiligungsplattform ist natürlich nicht schlecht, weil da kann man draus lernen. Also muss ich schon sagen,
Und ich glaube, so, wenn man jetzt den Unterausschuss neue Medien betrifft, äh anguckt, der äh parallel viele Debatten geführt hat, weil die ja eben auch gerade aktuell politisch waren,
dann sieht man auch da so gewisse Auswirkungen. Wenn man den anguckt, ist ja der Einzige, der so richtig Beteiligung hat, in dem Sinne, dass man dort live mitdiskutieren kann, wenn man interessiert ist. Da hat sich schon eine Menge getan. Das ist ein offeneres Klima,
würde ich schon sagen. Das würde ich aber jetzt natürlich nicht für das gesamte Parlament sagen.
Wär's denn nicht irgendwie vielleicht mal angemessen wirklich in der Öffentlichkeit so eine Enquete zu machen außerhalb des Bundestages ohne diesen Parteien Proports sozusagen so ein Forum.
Warum warum glaubst du was soll das bringen?
Weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, äh wenn jetzt hier äh ist immer eine Hinderlich war, dass so der Bundestags da reingrätscht und man konnte zwar sachliche Diskussionen im Hinterzimmer äh führen, aber nicht in der Öffentlichkeit.
könnte man sich ja sozusagen mal Bild äh machen und.
Auch in der öffentlichen Sitzung schon auch sachlich debattiert worden so. Ist ja nicht also der der Punkt ist ja,
ähm dieser dieser Bildungsaspekt. Am Anfang haben wir alle gesagt, ja, da da gehen die Abgeordneten alle raus als ähm Leute mit Ahnung vom Netz und so. Den den Effekt hat's natürlich, finde ich, auch teilweise gegeben. Grad so bei Abgeordneten, die,
manchen, also grad so in Projektgruppen, wo jetzt nicht ihr spezielles Interessengebiet ist, echt wenig Ahnung hatten. Also das gibt es schon. Wir haben da ja auch viel erklärt,
also kommt ja auch dazu. Aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch nichts, wo aus dem die Öffentlichkeit einen unmittelbaren Nutzen zieht, außer vielleicht mittelbar. Ja.
Denkst du denn, dass die beteiligten Politiker da einen Nutzen für sich draus gezogen.
Oh ja, Profilierungsmäßig? Ja, ne.
Meine ich jetzt nicht, nicht so persönlichen Vorteil, das meinte ich jetzt weniger, sondern das ist sozusagen auch in den Bundestag hinein eine Verbesserung des Netzverständnisses bewirkt hat.
Hm, also gemessen.
Meine immerhin ist das Thema ja mal auf die Agenda gesetzt worden, dass es sicherlich an sich schon mal ganz gut äh dass das stattgefunden hat.
Auf jeden Fall, na klar, äh hat die Bedeutung äh
Angehoben und äh das siehst du ja natürlich auch bis hoch zur Regierungschefin, dass das plötzlich Thema ist, aber ich meine, das war doch woanders, ja, in jeder Zeitung kannst du das ja sehen. Also, gemessen an der Gesamtanzeige der Parlamentarier war natürlich letztlich da mit den siebzehn Abgeordneten nur wenige,
paar hundertsechshundertdreiundzwanziger oder fünfundvierzig oder die aktuelle Zahl grade ist, aber,
so ist natürlich sozusagen der Einfluss auf Gesamtparlament vielleicht gering, aber ähm die Tatsache, dass es eben öffentlich war,
und das eben doch ganz schön viele Leute den Stream geguckt haben und also zumindest eine Berichterstattung gehabt von da ich na ja also ähm,
ist schon finde,
der Stellenwert, diese Art von Politik, so, ich will das nicht in der Netzpolitik nennen, weil das nicht der richtige Begriff ist. Also der ist größer.
hat schon gewonnen, glaube ich schon. Und letztlich äh haben viele Parlamentarier aber in der Zeit einfach nicht nur wegen der Oquett, sondern einfach weil die Entwicklung äh,
So ist in den letzten zwei Jahren äh begriffen, dass es halt kaum noch Gesetze gibt, die nicht äh irgendeinen technologischen,
irgendeinen Bezug zur Technologie haben. Ich glaube, das ist jetzt aber einfach auch Alltagswissen. Okay, es gibt bestimmt ein paar Ausnahmen,
aber ist ja auch genau die Zeit, wo die Parlamentarier jetzt plötzlich alle ein iPad haben, äh wo der.
Ja
Der der Arbeitsalltag ist schon auch erschreckend, den du da im Bundestag siehst. Da hat mich auch teilweise sehr gestört.
Papier.
Sehr unkonzentriert. Ähm ein bisschen so wie ihr, also nebenbei und liest mir jetzt. Das ist in diesen äh
ist einfach in diesen Ausschüttungen genauso. Die haben schlappe Papier vor sich, sie haben C3 vor uns, hast einen Laptop, du hast das iPad, Telefon
nebenbei schwarze mit den Kollegen, das ist, ich fand das auch häufig gegenüber, zum Beispiel, wenn du wir haben auch Leute eingeladen, noch andere Sachverständige,
Themen. Äh es war oft so, dass dann nur drei wirklich zugehört haben. Und den Modus beobachte ich jetzt überall. Das ist ja in Akademier,
Es bisschen unterschiedlich, aber äh grad so jetzt bei mir sind ja immer sehr viele Technikwissenschaftler, so mit denen ich nichts zu tun habe, ist ganz häufig. Das ist natürlich führt zu einer Unkonzentriertheit und auch zu einer Unfokussierung und zu einer Verflachung,
Ich habe das oft erlebt, dass du.
Also, Computer verbieten im Bundestag.
Nein, nein, nein, war nicht selten, dass du montags hast, ein Thema auf der Agenda,
Sie ist schon morgens irgendwie, wenn du losfährst, dann siehst du irgendwas Ticket über die PA. Und oft ist es so, äh wenn die Sitzung dann vorbei war, dann hast du ähm die ganze Stellungnahmen, den jetzt politischen Sprecher, wenn's einen Bezug hat,
Ich frage mich, wann die, haben die das alle gelesen und geschrieben, ja, das ist halt so ein bisschen diese, diese, diese Beschleunigung,
Hat mich schon unnachdenklich gemacht. Erklärt mir auch viel.
Das ist quasi der das das Internet, das Social Media und Internet induzierte ADHS äh erhält nun auch Einzug in den Bundestag.
Ja, schon ernsthaft, natürlich. Wie woanders auch.
Im richtigen Leben.
Also es ist vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen stärker, weil natürlich äh Abgeordnete haben sehr vollgepackten,
diese Klischee von da sind wir nicht arbeiten, ist einfach schlicht unwahr, wie echt, also hohes Arbeitspensum.
Im Moment du hast allerdings.
Pausen, ey, fand ich unerhört. Wir haben da immer pausenlos geplant. Ich weiß nicht, wann die essen. Da kommt dann immer so ein Käferwagen mit so einem Brötchen. Ich ich glaube, da würde ich wahnsinnig, wenn ich da arbeiten würde.
Du hast ja aber auch nur die äh Kontakt zu den Jungs gehabt, die was die sich tatsächlich engagieren. Die irgendwie da tätig sind, ne. Das muss ja dann vielleicht mal, du hast ja siebzehn von sechshundert noch was.
Ich weiß nicht gerade, wie viel Zünder hier gibt, so sechshundertdreißig, also sechshundertvierzig, sind bestimmt. Ja, natürlich, ist eine Auswahl, aber sehr unterschiedliche Charaktere an Parlamentariern da gewesen.
Vielleicht so was mich, was mich nochmal wirklich interessieren würde, weil du ja schon sehr ähm,
ja, emotionslos und analytisch darüber berichtest, wo hast du dich denn mal richtig aufgeregt.
Ich habe mich oft total.
Sich doch andauernd also ich meine, man hat die die Enquete war äh eigentlich nicht auszuhalten, ja. Es war teilweise sehr schwierig. Ich meine, ich
müssen wir jetzt gar nicht im Detail drauf eingehen, das ist sicherlich sehr schwierig war, äh bestimmten Sachverständigen da bei ihren Stellungen äh und Äußerungen oder so überhaupt äh zuzuhören
das stelle ich mir durchaus als Herausforderung vor, vor allem wenn man über zwei Jahre da Menschen hat, die ganz offensichtlich ähm,
entweder es wirklich schaffen, einem selbst ein ein Argument einfach komplett nicht wahrzunehmen über zwei Jahre oder das mit einer, also das finde ich ja so im politischen, in der, in der Berufspolitik sehr interessant,
dass die Menschen, es gibt eine psychologische Mechanismus, wenn du eine Frage stellst oder eine Anregung gibt, dass der Mensch diese irgendwie auf die Bezug nimmt,
und das ist ja das erste, was du, was du als Berufspolitiker ähm dir abgewöhnst, ja, dass dass du egal welche Frage kommst, du bekommst, du das sagst, was du sagen möchtest,
unabhängig davon, wie die Frage lautet.
Machen manche äh Sprecher auch.
Das funktioniert sehr gut, weil du
Äh weil du äh weil es weil es äh quasi du spielst quasi mit der Kommunikation und sagst, ja genau, also auf diese Frage äh antworte ich wie folgt und antwortest halt, gibt's überhaupt gar keinen Bezug zu der Frage. Und äh wenn du das höflich tust,
ähm muss der andere die Grenze überschreiten zu sagen, sie haben auf meine Frage nicht geantwortet, die Frage lautete.
Ist ja interessant, dass du das sagst, Lino, ich dachte immer, das wäre eine Eigenschaft von Männern, aber das offenbar nur von politischen Männern.
Ich weiß nicht, ist das eine Eigenschaft von mir? Willst du mir.
Also aber vielleicht habe ich die falsch interpretiert. Von mir. Nee, nicht alle Männer sind gleich Ledos.
Aber andere sind gleich. Okay, also ist äh man beobachtet es in der Politik, dass dass diese dass diese, dass das eigentlich konstant so stattfindet.
Gradet ist häufig so, dass man, wenn man auf den Punkt nicht kommen will, Mama hat einen großen Bogen auf. Aber das mache ich auch. Also, ich meine, da bin ich ja nicht fern. Das ist ein politisches Instrument ausweichen.
Und wie kommt man, wie kommt man damit klar, als jemand, der äh aus der Wissenschaft kommt, der, sage ich mal, an ähm,
ja vielleicht einer Faktendiskussion interessiert ist, ja? Also ich finde mich persönlich treibt das in den Wahnsinn, wenn ich ein Argument äh vortrage und merke, dieses Argument wird also wird aktiv ignoriert.
Äh glaube, ich meine, jeder ist immer äh in unterschiedlichen Rollen, ne. Äh ich habe schnell gelernt, dass man da nicht als, dass ich mir,
bin ja Notwissenschaftlerin, dass man da nicht als Aktivistin oder als Wissenschaftlerin ist, sondern dass das ein politischer Raum ist. Das meint man
total schnell. Natürlich passt man sich auch ein bisschen an. Aber in den Projektgruppen war das teilweise auch nicht so emotional und aufgebracht, sondern
da hat man das wirklich auch versucht sachlich auszuloten, wo kann man hier wirklich zu 'nem Konsens kommen? Was ist eigentlich wirklich grad der Sachstand? Weil manchmal umstritten. Ähm.
Der Grund gewesen sein, warum äh in den Projektgruppen dagegen gestimmt wurde, die öffentlich zu haben. Dass die sagen, ey Jungs, wenn wir das jetzt auch noch öffentlich machen, dann können wir uns ja gar nicht unterhalten.
Sie haben das auch explizit. Also sie haben gesagt, naja, wenn wir das öffentlich machen, dann ist das alles wieder Schaufenster. Wenn.
Das heißt, es ist sozusagen die Voraussetzung dafür, dass man sich normal unterhalten kann.
Nee, aber ich weiß nicht, ob das so richtig stimmt, denn es gibt ja immer noch eine Ebene darunter, noch informeller, nämlich die Ob-Leute-Runde,
Also es gibt eben im Bundestag wie in jedem sozialen Gebilde viele Schichten der Kommunikation. Die Frage ist doch eigentlich, hätte sich überhaupt jemand für die Projektgruppen interessiert, wenn sie so öffentlich gemacht hätten,
Also ich denke, dass der ganze Verlauf auch mit der Onlinebeteiligung ein anderer gewesen wäre, wenn man diese Entscheidung am Anfang anders gefällt hätte,
Denn dann hätten sich überhaupt erst Communitys bilden können, die sich wirklich inhaltlich mit der Projektgruppe zusammen äh irgendwie an Lösungen machen. Die Entscheidung war früh klar,
Und irgendwann ist dann auch das Ritual weggegangen, dass man am Anfang darüber abstimmt, weil war ja sowieso mal klar, wer die Mehrheit hat.
Ich glaube fast,
Wir sind da einfach noch nicht so weit. Ja, also nicht nur der Bundestag, sondern auch meine man sieht ja auch, welche Schwierigkeiten die Piraten da zum Beispiel mit ihren öffentlichen äh Sitzungen äh haben, ja, da fehlt sie nämlich genau das Gleiche äh Element so. Keiner will dann so richtig.
Würdest du das akzeptabel finden.
Hallo, ich ich möchte was sagen. Du hast meine Frage nicht beantwortet, Konstanz.
Wo ich mich aufgeregt habe. Aber ich habe mich ganz oft aufgeregt. Also ich meine, ich bin bestimmt kein
keine Mimose oder so, überhaupt nicht. Also ich kann mich auch schnell wieder abregen. Ich kann mich schnell aufregen, wer abregt. Aber ich ähm ich habe besonders geärgert, wenn det äh wirklich respektlos war. Das kommt manchmal vor,
ähm es gab aber auch mal so äh so Kleinigkeiten, das ist.
Also respektlos von einer, wenn dir respektlos gegenüber getreten wurde, von einer Person oder.
Halten sich zum Beispiel einfach nicht an die Regeln, ja? Im Sinne wie eben beispielsweise vorhin hatte, die kommen einfach nicht wieder. Das sind da die ganzen Sachverständigen sitzen, die auch teilweise von weit anreisen. Ich bin ja nun
Berlin. Ich hatte nie weit so. So. Äh oder aber wenn ähm,
was mich oft richtig geärgert hat, war, wenn das wieder Kungeleien gab. Ich gehöre hinten rum, man hat sich irgendwie so und so geeinigt. Äh
Entschuldigung, wozu haben wir überhaupt eine sachliche Diskussion geführt? Das ärgert mich dann schon. Oder aber Realitätsverweigerung,
Also das war bei der Diskussion in den Chartsräumen natürlich mehrfach begegnet, wo ich dann sage, hallo, so, die Krankheit überhaupt nicht einsehen, wenn jemand,
so eine Realität nicht akzeptiert zum Beispiel, die eben die Frage wie sieht die ähm die Tatsache, äh,
nicht legale Rechtsgrundlage für den kannste nachlesen fünfundzwanzig Paper äh von Juristen und dann schreiben die aber wat andere denn.
Ihre Papiere und das kann mich echt ärgerlich machen. Oder aber auch, also,
habe mich eingangs also hat am Ende so ein bisschen nachgelassen, auch oft über die anderen Sachverständigen geärgert, dass ich einfach also denke, okay, wieso äh lassen die sich so einen Gemeinden in die Fraktion,
Aber gut, das muss jeder für sich entscheiden. Das hat mich teilweise schon geärgert,
Aber wenn manchmal auch so wirklich so Kleinigkeiten sowas wie äh Fischer, der Axel Fischer, der Vorsitzende Kommission.
Über Dinkel, den kann man doch nicht.
Macht sein Mikro nicht zu beim Lästern und so,
Ja. Oder auch wenn sie wieder mal vergessen haben, die Sachverständigen zu nennen und sich wieder in die Fraktion eingemeint zum fünften Mal wiederholen muss so. Aber es waren auch viele positive Momente, habe ich jetzt schon erwähnt,
Also, ich habe mich da jetzt auch nicht permanent aufgeregt, weil du wirst doch irgendwie gelassen und nach einer Weile äh dann kannst du das spielen. Am Anfang habe ich mich so ein bisschen mehr geärgert,
Also du lernst einfach bestimmte Rituale kennen. Du findest es zwar immer noch doof irgendwie, aber.
Du weißt, dass der Hase da jetzt immer so lang läuft.
Was waren denn so die die positiven Momente?
Na ja, ich habe mich natürlich über manches in drin war äh fand ich fand ich total toll, gerade so am Anfang, wo dann auch so wurde ja so eine Welle von Beteiligung gehabt, also dass Leute sich da irgendwie so,
haben oder Kommentare ich hab den Blog noch also ich hab,
Ähm ich fand auch das Interesse der der Media am Anfang ziemlich cool, also du konntest sozusagen auf Sachen auf Knackpunkte hinweisen und Leute äh also Aufmerksamkeit dahin lenken so und das was dir persönlich wichtig ist an Themen. Fand ich gut. So ähm,
natürlich, also da, ich habe ein paar Abgeordnete kennengelernt, die ich äh deren arbeite ich sehr schätze,
also wirklich auch echt zaubert. Det ist also da sind ein paar bei, die halte ich für Prototypische Parlamentarier und so und hätte ich gerne in meinem Wahlkreis, also sehr engagiert, immer sachlich. Also gibt halt,
Genauso diesen Gegentypen gegenüber diesem unsympathischen Berufspolitiker, der so wo die Klischees herkommen, das gibt es und das hat mich natürlich total erfreut.
Möchtest du sagen, wer das ist?
Äh das beste Wäsche ist für mich, Petersitte. Also ich bin, die kommt ja, äh ihr wart jetzt in Halle. Die war in jeder Sitzung immer, egal, welche Thema, die ist total sachlich,
Manchmal scherzen die darüber auch, weil natürlich äh da gibt es mal die CDU redet dann mal mit den Linken, wenn es Petrasitte ist,
Ja, weil die eben sehr sachlich sein kann. Und äh unglaubliche Arbeitspensum, immer gut vorbereitet, hat mich beeindruckt, ja. Äh davon gibt's aber mehr. Petra Zitter habe ich natürlich auch relativ eng,
weil wenn man manchmal in Gruppen und so, fand ich sehr beeindruckend, also ist eine Abgeordnete, wie ich mir
Wünsche also bildet sich eine Meinung, äh ist regelmäßig im Wahlkreis, äh versucht äh bedeutet, wird sie selbst als Fachpolitiker Bildungspolitik vor allen Dingen, um Medien und Bildung,
ähm auch äh die eigene Parteimeinung zu beeinflussen, also sozusagen ihre Position zu stärken. Äh interessiert sich ganz doll. Also diese diese,
haben ja viele Menschen auch nicht so, dass es sich überhaupt noch für euch begeistern können, was sie neu entdecken. Finde ich gut,
Und davon gibt's aber mehr Beispiele. Denn ähm also,
Ich glaube, du findest immer weniger von diesem Beispiel, umso mächtiger die Politiker werden, das ist so meine Erfahrung.
Was sagst du denn zu den ähm sicherten kennen einige der ähm wissenschaftlichen, ich glaube wissenschaftlichen Mitarbeiter.
Oder Fraktionsmitarbeiter, es gibt unterschiedliche.
Ja, äh die, die ich kennenlerne als Leute, die also echt auch noch mal ein riesiges Arbeitspensum haben, ähm das sind also quasi dann die die beiden oder die eine rechte Hand des jeweiligen Abgeordneten.
Ja.
sollte die auch mal nennen. Also bei der, also die sozusagen von den Oppositionsfraktionen kenne ich jetzt eigentlich alle, aber auch ein paar von äh FDP und CDU für die Linksfraktion war das vor allen Dingen Ilja Richter
wir brauen. Ähm da muss ich echt sagen und Jürgen Schäler, die haben richtig viel gearbeitet. Dann war der Sebastian Koch
aber jetzt der, der jetzt aufgehört hat, ist noch richtig eine Riege an Leuten, äh die sich auch ganz gut auskennt. Die haben sich alle so ihre Themen aufgeteilt. Dann ist da noch gewesen, teilweise. Da war dann eine Zeit lang weg weg wegen Auslandsaufenthalt. Aber es fällt mir gerade sein Name nicht ein.
Von wem der Mitarbeiter? Von der Linken oder.
Warte mal, ich komme gleich Philipp Otto. Genau, fand ick, also war auch eine angenehme Zusammenarbeit, muss ich echt sagen. Es gibt,
ja da eine Menge coole Leute.
Das waren jetzt alle von der, von der Linken. Bei den Grünen gibt's dann auch noch Leute.
Genau bei den Grünen hat er, also Christine, die hat, die ist einfach, ja, fit,
Fand ick, fand ick gut, aber man merkt natürlich auch, dass die Arbeitsumgebung in den Fraktionen ein bisschen unterschiedlich ist, hat ja auch jeder Partei so ein bisschen ihre Kultur
äh bei den bei den bei der SPD war das vor allen Dingen Johannes Keullbeck äh also finde ich auch eben sehr kompetenter vor allen Dingen aber im praktischen Betrieb,
gut durch.
In der zweiten äh Riege.
Ja, genau, die Mitarbeiter.
So die die Guten, ne? Weil Philipp Otto sagst, nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Philipp Otto, der bei engagiert ist oder ist es.
Nee, das ist derselbe, glaube ich.
Philipp Otto. Okay, alles klar.
Eine Wahrheit eine Weile, ey, der hat dann ick weiß nicht, ich weiß leider gerade nicht, wo ich glaube, in in in den USA.
Ja, okay, er war ja auch mal bei Lok Buch schon zu Gast in Ausgabe.
Also der hat natürlich jetzt sich mit der Fahrer der Urheberrechte auseinandergesetzt.
Ja ja klar, das ist ja sein.
Natürlich auch ziemlich doll umstritten, klar. Also ähm es gab natürlich auch Unterstützung aus dem CCC, sehr wenig, aber,
Auch ähm also ähm zum Beispiel, was die Anhörung betrifft, dass man nochmal einen anderen Sachverständigen blenden kann. Aber es gibt auch ähm insbesondere zwei Leute, die,
mich etwas unterstützt haben, ansonsten war die Interesse sehr gering.
Möchtest sagen, wer das war?
Nein, ick, also nich, müssen Sie selber sagen, wenn Sie, wenn Sie Lust haben,
Also keine Ahnung. Also für einmal ist es also immer kam mit in äh der etwa,
vor allen Dingen ginge da um Netze und Zugang und Struktur und Sicherheit, da war Mike Thorsten Schröder da. Fand ich ziemlich cool, weil das auch Arbeit, wenn man sich dann als
verständige nochmal in so eine Anhörung setzt, fand ich, fand ich gut. Aber man hat äh ansonsten eine ähnliche Reaktion beobachten können, wie auch sonst in der Netzgemeinde.
Dass er zu wenig kommt.
Jana, weil das natürlich auch schwer ist, äh wenn du nicht weißt, wer gerade die Diskussionsstand ist. Ähm und ich persönlich, äh ich habe mir das auch überlegt, weil ich am Anfang auch wie wie trage ich das rein in den CCC, aber das ist also ich werde nicht.
Das ist schwierig. Ich meine,
seht, wie viel du selbst hast, lernen müssen, um überhaupt erstmal zu begreifen, äh wo du bist, kann man ja dann wiederum auch ganz gut nachvollziehen. Und ich glaube, das war auch so eine Wirkung, die ich auch so wahrgenommen habe. Da ist dann so ein Apparat auf einmal äh in Gang äh gekommen
denen man gar nicht so richtig einschätzen kann, ja, wie autark ist der, wie gut kann man da jetzt eigentlich zuarbeiten und es hat sich ja letztlich auch gezeigt, äh in gewisser Hinsicht, dass obwohl da jetzt Interesse bestand äh über oder andere
sich da einzubringen, dass das eben auch seine Grenzen hat und das ist eben das, was ich vorhin auch meinte, ja, also vielleicht ist die Zeit einfach noch nicht gekommen, ja. Vielleicht äh.
Vielleicht kommt sie auch nicht. Ich weiß.
Da werde ich mir nicht so sicher. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie vermuten, dass niemand jemals E-Mail benutzt. Also.
Nee, in der Nähe, das ist der Unterschied zwischen und und wisst ihr, diesen diesen Unterschied.
Ach so, na gut, dann spielst du jetzt vielleicht auch was anderes an, als als ich jetzt meine. Ich ich sage einfach nur dieser äh Beteiligungsprozess und überhaupt dieses Finden von,
Konsens, mit Netzwerkzeugen. Das ist, ich meine, das
auch bei den Piraten, wo das einen relativ hohen Stellenwert äh schon genießt. Es ist nicht nur umstritten, sondern eben auch teilweise einfach
äh auch nochmal eine harte Schule, durch die man da äh gehen muss. Also ich denke, dass man da insgesamt trotz äh vorhandenen Wunschdenkens einfach noch einen gewissen Weg.
Gehen hat, bis man eben so eine ähm Erkenntnisdichte hat, ja, also äh auch eine Wikipedia äh brauchte äh äh viele, viele Anläufe, bis sie letztlich das Modell gefunden hat, unter dem,
Projekt dann eben auch funktioniert hat und das ist dann einfach auch so eine Frage, einfach des gesellschaftlichen Fortschritts, der sich erstmal abzeichnen muss und der dann insbesondere auch auf die politische Kultur soweit dann äh abfärbt, auch natürlich durch Generationswechsel. Ich
wäre überhaupt nicht überrascht, wenn wir hier in zehn Jahren äh äh sitzen,
und so etwas wie eine äh Beteiligung an einem Entwurfsprozess zu einem Gesetz oder im Rahmen einer Enquete oder oder eines Ausschusses
dass äh äh dass das dann zumindest in den Bereichen, die das digitale äh äh betreffen dann schon normal ist.
ich jetzt wirklich nicht überrascht. Ist vielleicht eine eine steile These, aber überrascht wäre ich jetzt nicht. Und ähm sehe, dass
durchaus als etwas, was noch kommen kann. Aber vielleicht bin ich da auch äh Verbesserung, also unverbesserlicher Optimist.
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also, du gehst halt von einer gewissen äh von einem gewissen Ziel aus, wenn du das zeigst, weil du das für erstrebenswerte achtest.
Ja, weil ich das auch für ich halte das für unvermeidlich.
Unvermeidlich. Also nicht erschrebenswert, aber unvermeidlich.
Ich halte es sowohl für erstrebenswert als auch für unvermeidlich und weil es ja für unvermeidlich halte, deswegen sehe ich das in der Zukunft nicht, weil ich das unbedingt haben will.
Onlinebeteiligung in ihrem Lauf.
Hält weder Ochsen noch Esel.
Aus.
Weiß nicht, ich bin tatsächlich skeptischer geworden, das muss ich auch echt.
Na gut, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Nicht gedacht selbst als Benutzer wenn man das so will ich glaub die wollte ich heute nicht mehr so schreiben,
Ja, das ist leider so. Äh,
es gibt ja auch nach wie vor natürlich äh kein Problem. Also es gibt zwei zwei Lösungen letztlich nicht da oder vielleicht sogar drei. Äh deiner ist die Treueproblematik. Dafür gibt's aber auch sonst im Netz keine Lösung. Eine zweite äh ist die legitimatorische Frage,
die wird sich immer stellen. Die dritte ist natürlich die nach der Abstimmung.
Ähm also da ist, wenn eine Votingkomponente, die äh die eine Folge hat, eine konkrete Folge, also die man nicht nur macht, um Meinungsbild einzuholen, sondern die eine diese Probleme sind ungelöst. Und da bin ich natürlich ähm,
Die Wahlcomputer und Online-Wahlen betrifft, äh.
Dabei
ein ich rede ja von offenen Prozessen. Ich rede jetzt nicht unbedingt äh um eine von geheimen Abstimmungen, die auch äh geheim zu sein haben, sondern äh dass man einfach wo eigentlich ohnehin ein offener Prozess und ich meine, letztlich waren ja auch die Abstimmungen in der Enquete waren ja öffentlich.
Oder? Da ist ja nichts Keimen abgestimmt worden so. Von daher äh tangiert es ja diesen Bereich.
Mal gucken, ob wir da auch noch rausgekommen wäre.
Ja, das äh könnte ich mir fast vorstellen, ja.
Ich hätte gerne mal double Blind abgestimmt gehabt. Ich hätte es gerne mal gesehen.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber, glaube ich, auch langsam mal äh zum Ende kommen. Ich meine, das ist eine Spezialsendung, die darf auch mal länger sein, aber das äh haben wir.
Bildern von Limit üblicherweise.
Minuten, wir müssen da gleich noch ein bisschen was rausschneiden.
Es muss auf eine CD passen, ne? Quatsch.
Nein, ach, das schaffen wir nie. Ich schaffe ja ungefähr eine von von dreißig Sendungen. Ähm,
würdest du es wieder tun?
Ähm oh, das ist natürlich eine harte Frage. Ähm.
Oder wie blickst du jetzt auch zurück? Ja, ich meine, äh man kann immer, also wenn jemand sagt, das war eine interessante Erfahrung, dass es äh für mich die Übersetzung von ähm das war Scheiße, ich bin froh, dass es vorbei ist.
Nee, nee, nee, das war Kinder, das hat Erfahrung. Also so äh so wurde ich auch nicht irgendwie verstanden werden. Also das ist schon mehr,
A also den politischen Prozesse und Detail zu kennen ist natürlich für mich irgendwie ein politischer Mensch, interessiert mich, das ist wichtig und das werde.
Mhm. Hilft auch mehr zu verstehen wahrscheinlich, was.
Fertig auch schlicht nutzen in der Zukunft. Also ich meine, ich plane weiterhin Einfluss auf die Politik zu nehmen, die mich interessiert. Das ist mein mein Ziel,
Und ich glaube auch, dass äh der Club an sich auch dazu natürlich was beitragen kann durch seine Expertise so. Insofern ist das ein Mehrwert. Trotzdem würde ich mir das natürlich überlegen. Also ich meine, das muss man halt neben Beruf und Ehrenamt noch in seiner Teilzeit eintakten,
Wurde ich mir, glaube ich, schon überlegen. Ich glaube, ich würde auch anders mit dem mit der Organisation für die gerne mal auch ein Gesicht bin irgendwie. Ähm umgehen wollen.
Mhm. Es gab eine Aufwandsentschädigung.
Ja, es gab eine Aufwandsentschädigung.
Muss man ja auch mal, also das, das, die Frage.
Wusste ich am Anfang nicht.
Also wie privilegiert muss man sein, um um diese Position wahrnehmen zu können, ne? Also ich meine, wir haben da äh einige Lobbyisten an den Tischen gehabt, da deren Jahresgehälter auf äh auf Wikipedia stehen.
Ist deren Arbeit.
Genau, das ist deren Arbeit so, dass äh äh und wir haben natürlich dann jemanden wie du, der nebenbei durchaus äh ja äh beruflich und ehrenamtlich tätig war.
Ja, ich musste erstmal bei meinem Arbeitgeber durchkriegen und dann musste der beantragen. Das ist ja äh war auch nicht so leicht. Äh also meine meine Hochschule musste erst mal überzeugt werden, dass äh,
dass ich das machen darf. Also das ist so ein bisschen du hast natürlich auch keine Zuarbeit. Also viele haben.
Das ist was, was Markus sehr äh beklagt hat, ne, dass da dass die Lobby ist in dem Prinzip ein ein Office im im Hintergrund, in in der Hinterhand haben, ja, dass.
Genau. Ich muss sagen, bei bei mir ist es so, dass natürlich die die ganzen Mitarbeiter in der Fraktion von von der Linkspartei
die haben da auch eine Menge Arbeit gemacht. Also ich habe auch viel nicht geschafft. Ich habe es eigentlich immer geschafft, das zu lesen, damit ich auf dem Stand bin, aber ich habe nicht immer geschafft, die Texte zu schreiben, die man hätte oder,
schaffen müssen, muss ich echt zugeben mit, weil manchmal nicht machbar. Und ich hab natürlich auch noch zwei besucht, also was mich thematisch interessiert, konnte ich nicht alles besuchen. Es hat sich ja teilweise überlappt,
Wahrheit nicht anders zu machen, denn der Schedu war immer, also wir haben zum Beispiel auch nur in den Sitzungs,
war immer klar, dass wir uns an das Parlament halten, obwohl wir die Hälfte der Leute darstellen. Es war immer klar, dass wir die parlamentarischen Regeln einhalten. Aus irgendeinem Grund, ich weiß nicht warum.
Immer so gemacht.
Ja äh wir müssen Frauen auch Kleider tragen. Haben wir immer schon so gemacht. Ich finde das klingt in einem Moment. Ich mag mich diesen Regeln dann auch nicht unterwerfen und ich habe auch eine gewisse Lust daran, das jedes Mal anzumerken. Fanden, glaube ich, viele auch nervig. Mehr,
Also ich glaube,
also irgendwie auf die Frage zu antworten wäre wahrscheinlich, ich würd's nochmal machen, hätte aber jetzt mehr Bauchschmerzen, weil ich ja schon weiß, was Gamer. Ich würde aber auch ein paar Sachen nicht mehr machen. Äh ich für manche Sachen würde ich mir nicht mehr die Arbeit machen, zu einer gleichen Sondervotum schreiben,
Also wer den kleinkarierten Streit da zwischen den äh verschiedenen immer gleichen Leuten würde ich mir nicht mehr, würde ich lieber ein gutes Sondervotum schreiben.
Sondervotum. Was meinst du damit.
Hm? Na, alles, was du, du hast ja das Recht, als Sachverständiger, als jeder, jedes Mitglied der Enquete-Kommission. Kannst du halt deine eigene Meinung abgeben. Und das ist halt äh viel effizienter teilweise als äh sich da auseinanderzusetzen.
Das heißt, du kannst die ganze Debatte sparen und schreibst einfach zu allem deinen eigenen Kram.
Machen. So ist natürlich nicht der Arbeitsmodus und so haben sie auch nicht dann aber das würde ich, denke ich, wenn ich das nochmal machen würde, eher machen. Ich bin ein bisschen gewarnt worden. Äh Mitglieder anderer Enquete-Kommissionen in in Land und Bund oder früherer äh haben mit mir gesprochen,
so in der Anfangsphase. Also ich also ich habe das einfach gar nicht so richtig verfolgt. Es klar, was die mir gesagt haben, nach.
Du hattest, aber du wusstest nicht, dass es das war.
Na die haben mich schon teilweise so gewarnt oder mir so ein bisschen und den den erklärt ist ja auch nett gemeint, fand ich fand ich echt nett.
Naja, würdet ihr das machen? Fragt euch doch mal. Ähm hättest du das denn mal, nimm dich mal zuerst. Ja, Tim.
Ähm ich ich glaube gar nicht, dass ich auch nur in die äh in die Situation äh käme, gefragt zu werden.
Jetzt stell dir doch mal vor, du würdest gefragt werden.
Nee, ehrlich gesagt.
Jetzt habe ich dir das erzählt, ich hätte dich überm Anfang fragen sollen.
Nee, das ist auch nicht so mein Modus zu viel Papier.
Du hast es doch digital, außer die Tischvorlagen.
Ja, aber es ist ja.
Also die Antwort wäre klar, nein.
Ich mache eigentlich lieber immer.
Das ist ja auch eine Form vom Machen, aber eine andere Form. Ja. Eine anstrengende Form.
Ja, ist eine andere Form. Für mich ist das, glaube ich, nix.
Bei dir, Lenas?
Auch nicht ins Parlament oder so.
Ich auch nicht. Das esse ich jetzt schon gar nicht mehr.
Ich bin auch nicht in einer Partei. Ja, aber.
Gab es jemals eine, die äh für dich sexy erschienen zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt, wo du dir mal überlegt hast, da könnte ich eventuell Mitglied werden? Nie.
Ich finde das an sich nicht interessant.
Da haben wir echt viel gemeinsam. Ich bin ja dann auch nicht. War das mit dir, Linus?
Ähm nach dem Gespräch mit mehreren Enquete-Sachverständigen denke ich, dass ich das machen würde,
aber große Sorge in so eine Art der Resignation zu verfallen. Also da müsste ich mit mir selber
irgendwie 'ne ein Modus finden, dass ich da nicht resigniere, dann nicht abschalte, weil ich denke, dass man da relativ schnell in so 'n erlernte Hilflosigkeit verfallen kann und ähm dann ähm ja, resigniert und sagt dann,
surfe ich lieber gleichzeitig im Internet, das wäre was, was ich ähm auf jeden Fall vermeiden wollen würde, um meinem eigenen Anspruch da gerecht zu bleiben. Aber wo ich durchaus auch die Gefahr sehen würde, bei denen Frustra, frustrierenden Erfahrungen, die da durchaus auch geschildert werden,
dass das passieren könnte. Also das wär wär,
die Angst, die ich da hätte, ähm natürlich auch die Kollision mit mit ja Beruf und oder Ehrenamt,
ähm.
Ja, könntest du das machen? Würdest du, also wirst du zeitlich.
Na, ich glaube, da ich, da ich ja geringe Ansprüche an meinen Geldbeutel habe, würde ich eventuell einfach äh in hätte ich in so einer Situation.
Weniger gearbeitet.
Weniger oder nicht mehr gearbeitet.
Ey, die Entscheidung war so, ich denke, das waren so vierhundert Euro im Monat oder so weiter.
Oh, okay. Äh ich hätte die jetzt ein bisschen höher eingeschätzt. Okay, nee, dann hätte.
Viel war das nicht, ne.
Weiter arbeiten müssen.
Club Albert hat das mal rausgerechnet. Ich denke, das ist äh nicht zu versteuern.
Ja, Alba hat das, Alva hat das mal ausgerechnet, als sie ihm von Pfefe vorgeworfen wurde, er ließe sich da jetzt den Aktivisten arsch vergolden oder irgendwie sowas? Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe mich eigentlich eher darüber geärgert, wie wir dazu geschrieben haben. Einfach ich meine, ich denke, er wird an vielen Punkten wie leider wie immer Recht haben, was mich ja schon immer besonders fuchst, aber ich fand ihn natürlich auch häufig ungerecht,
das ist eben so, wenn man in der Kommission sitzt und sich Berichterstattung unterzuzieht hat oft so, dass man sich darüber ärgert, einfach weil man seine Zeit reingesteckt hat und dann kriegt man die Kritik ab und
Ich will aber nicht in dieses Muster fallen, weißt du, so es fällt mir so schwer. Aber beide fand ich schon teilweise sehr ungerecht, auch weil der natürlich teilweise aus erster Hand wusste, was wirklich war,
Na ja.
Also ja, das ist so das für mein kurzer Punkt. Und ich würde auch, ich würde auch in den Bundestag gehen, aber ja, aber nur wenn äh nur äh ohne Partei und das ist, glaube ich, aussichtslos.
Ohne Partei.
Ich ich bin doch nicht verrückt und gehe eine Partei.
Na ja gut, dann hast du aber eigentlich wenig Chancen. Die einzige Möglichkeit besteht dann darin, direkt mal drei zu gewinnen. Als Parteiloser, das ist eigentlich.
Richtig. Ja, aber das also mein mein also ich bin ein großer nach wie vor großer Feind des des Fraktionszwangs oder der Fraktionsdisziplin.
In der ersten Legislatur kannst du dich ja dem wieder setzen, dann kommst du zwar nie wieder ran, aber.
So und das äh deswegen müsste also ein Parlament, in dem ich äh wäre, müsste mich ohne Partei äh dulden und.
Ja, was ist mit der Sexin, das der macht, du könntest Einfluss nehmen auf die Bereiche, die dich interessieren.
Das glaube ich nicht, dass ich jemals äh äh ausreichenden Einfluss gewinnen könnte in einem Parlament. Ja. Das da glaube ich, da da stehen mir meine.
Die sich hinter ihnen stellen. Ich verstehe das gar nicht.
Nee, das äh halte ich für unwahrscheinlich, dass das passieren würde.
Na gut, aber deine Antwort letztlich auf die Frage ist, also wer mit der Onkel, könntest du dir schon vorstellen, so zu wunden? Wenn du auch nicht so furchtbar gern.
Großen Vorbehalt, ja.
Okay.
Also unter unter sehr großem Vorbehalt und nach langer Sen äh Meditation.
Betrogen, gell? Alkohol.
Auf Asset. So, nein, äh also es wäre äh schwierig. Ich müsste einfach.
Einfach Präsident. Direkt gewählt vom Volk.
Das wäre natürlich, das ist sowieso natürlich die politische Position, in der ich mich am komfortabelsten wegen würde.
Klar. Diktator. Diktator.
Diktator, der Linusismus.
Aber es gibt aber noch diesen Winkpräsidenten. Es hat nicht viel geiler. Ey, bei uns heißt der Präsident.
Präsident. Ach so, ja, nee, nee, das wäre mir zu.
Schon richtiger Präsident sein.
Ja das äh.
Und ein Buggycar, das ist da geblieben.
Na ja, also.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, da würde ich also politisch wenn
Politik dann äh Gestaltung, ja? Und äh irgendwie den sogenannten Grüßaugust oder so oder irgendwelche ähm Ehrenposten oder sowas würden mich da weniger reizen, als tatsächlich mal.
Aber die Macht des Wortes hast du dann, wenn der Windpräsident bist.
Die Macht des Wortes, ja.
Da wirst du einfach Kanzler und ich werde Ehrenpräsident. Ich glaube, ich kann das ganz gut.
Ja, aber wie willst du denn, dann musst du erst mal Merkel entfernen? Das ist nicht so einfach. Na ja, ich weiß, wir haben bald Wahlen, weil ja, ja.
Genau. Wir machen jetzt erstmal die Sendung zu Ende. First things first und dann arbeiten wir noch weiter an der Revolution.
Ja, das machen wir dann aber jetzt unter Ausschluss der Öffentlichkeit in der Projektgruppe Linusismus.
Revolutionsprojektgruppe.
Gründen jetzt hier eine Enquete und untersuchen das mal.
Revolutionskomitee.
In unserem Hinterzimmer. Konstanze, vielen Dank für die Ausführung.
Vielen Dank, ich habe mich sehr gefreut, dich als Gästin gewinnen zu können. Dieser Gesichtsausdruck.
In Genderisierung Gästin, okay. Ja, ich fahre gerne bei euch. Ich bin ja schließlich auch ein langjähriger Fan.
Genau, du bist ja auch Podcasterin, das sollten wir auch nochmal erwähnen.
Oh ja, ein neues.
Genau.
Moderiere nicht. Bin da Gleichberechtigt Mitglied.
Ach so, ich dachte, du hast die äh Moderation.
Ich rede nur immer, wenn die nichts sagen.
So. Aber die anderen reden immer die ganze Zeit oder wie?
Sie sind jetzt beide nicht die Vierredner, ich glaube, ich muss da mehr schweigen.
Ernsthaft lassen, weißt du, so Schreiberlinge, ne, die kriegen's mal nicht.
Ja, na, vor allen Dingen sind sie ja doch etwas wie soll ich sagen, Helga hat auch schneller, ihr kriegt mehr Worte unter pro Minute.
Genau. Deutsch äh äh Org, der zugehörige äh Podcast. Nur Sprechfunk.
Der heißt Neusprechfunk.
Ja. Ist das Blog und der Neusprechfunk ist der Podcast. Ähm zusammen mit dem großen Kai Biermann und dem großen Martin Hase.
Alles sehr groß.
Die sexysten Podcaste, die wir außer euch haben,
Boah, der Schleim der Woche.
So, jetzt machen wir Schluss. Das war's. Vielen Dank.
Tschüss. Feierabend hier.
Tschüss.